them up I am so doing is this too hammed
up guys welcome to the wiggly
ball
God welcome to the weekly PLL this is is
this too hammed up am I this is my real
voice I'm sorry I'll stop doing all the
fake stuff welcome to the weekly B I'm
comic
storian oh my god well Benny went from
being quiet and only saying I am Groot
to being being completely hyper and
imbalanced being I don't know what
you're talking
about what was what was that saying you
never go full [__]
is never go full [__] all
right shut up Rob I'm trying to intro us
while I put
pop wait wait we do the intro then we'll
make sure they can hear you because they
probably can't anyway this still test
stream
three is it still test stream
three welcome to the weekly poll where
I'm going to interrupt those two guys
from saying what they're going to say
I'm comic story and that is stle of TV
little house that is Rob of of the
channel That We're on and that is our
secret boner David
secret boner crate all right can you
guys hear Rob so we can fix
this I see we are let's do it now before
we get 15 minutes in and the chat is
just filled with is working is it I
can't
what yeah no let's let's avoid it looks
good mine says stand by no mine says
stand by you're not live no no no no he
don't click on the test stream three
click on the weekly pull live oh we have
we have a live one yeah t is here
already oh yeah we're good whoops well
that's all right Rob hey Rob real quick
let me give you an actual real piece of
advice here for YouTube sake before I
guess we're done the intro now but go to
your top page you know how you can set
playlists up right now go to go to the
bottom one where you can set a do one up
and then there's an option to put live
now if you put it at the top it'll only
pop up when you do a live event it'll go
away when it's you're not doing
one
true no it's it's two seconds that way
we can get more people viewing this it's
two seconds two
seconds I don't see it I really
don't oh there it is you're running two
Live Events oh shoot
you
are oh God noises loud noises in my head
from a
commercial since when let's do it yeah
right every week it's like a new
discovery for just
us why why are we
[Music]
widescreen we're widescreen that's
that's
fun oh Rob I love you bud I love I love
you buddy sometimes I wonder though Rob
damn it Rob damn it Rob typical Rob I'm
sorry I'm I'm just jumping on the
vanwagon he doesn't want to go left out
yeah Bo yeah are you sure
and don't worry I'm going back through
the last month of putting all of the
weekly polls into my weekly poll podcast
uh playlist that I've been failing to do
yeah oh yeah yeah I probably should
tweet because I do
that yes hello everyone welcome to the
weekly po everyone wanted my real voice
I'm not supposed to fake
anything
no it's only
August you don't know when it is anymore
you're just like
ohes everywhere just like get what
shouldn't you be in a building and
they're like no it's this is school now
teachers just let let kids watch YouTube
all day
yeah I like how Dave combed his hair
trimmed the beard he's like if this
works I'm going to look good for it
exactly now fly the hell down like my
cad
again oh my
God they might be trolling
you I don't
know you sound fine to me my gosh really
quick let me just while we're figuring
this stuff out I want to ask I want to
question no question would you like to
POS the PO the question I want to pose
is this is nothing to do with the show
this is just have you guys seen that
YouTube ad for the Spider-Man fan film
no it always comes up for me whenever I
watch one of like Marvel explained or
the weekly poll or anything like that
and it's comic story in or Comics
reviews story in or uh or little house
uh when you watch your own channel which
is pretty much every day and it's this
fan film and I'm and when I because at
first I used to watch like YouTube
commercials not I used to of course I
would skip them but like I would look at
a YouTube commercial I go oh like that
looks pretty legit but then like there's
this Spider-Man fan film that I'm
looking at right now it's called the
stunning Spider-Man
reborn and it's uh this guy youtube.com
I can't he was too fast for me and I
can't pause of commercial but it
is it's just like like this guy is
jacked and he's in his backyard and he
has a full like cosplay Spider-Man
costume and he's like I'm going to do
this Spider-Man fan film with Venom and
Mary Jane and stuff and it's like I'm
like what are you doing like there's no
way somebody could pull that off in
their backyard if yeah I mean like he
does it like I just imagine like just
shitty green screen no there's no green
screen it is it is green all right Green
from the like the FAS behind him like
it's really bizarre oh um but I just
thought no
good
okay wait do I have to Auto intube
Network n4gtv philed being on this great
tip where you can Auto add videos to
your um playlist if it contains certain
keywords so I'm just Auto adding
everything on my channel like that I've
been missing that I missed in the
playlist good
idea it's a good tip it is a good tip
and the guy who did the voiceover for
The tip's Amazing that's what I hear
it's me by the
way that's what I hear from you every
day that I'm amazing yeah I know I am
thanks so
much so yeah you want to uh oh stream I
don't think we're live Benny for the
whole stream oh we'll have no one in 10
minutes okay we're back to being live
now well I didn't know we were down all
right I'm going to promote it hold on
guys uh can you guys hear me at all out
there yeah let's see what if the chat
can hear them if they
can we'll just hit the tarmac man you
guys should be able to hear me if you
guys can't hear me then maybe I'll just
like bail out I don't know no you can't
bail out I know I'm messing around
silent it up and just be like just mime
the entire podcast yeah exactly I can't
do this anymore write stuff down on a
piece of paper and show it to the camera
yeah just you should all say I am Groot
the whole time yeah we tried that it
didn't work well
well all
right but maybe it'll work with us and
and not you Benny Rob's very low but
they can hear
you I'm very low but they can hear me
all
right God damn it these fish sense me
near their location there no way to like
save default settings for that
program which is like xplit is better
than OBS because OBS was giving me
problems yeah all
here we go I'm adjusting my EOD okay um
important things first all
right let's
see no Rob's fishing and trying to fix
things I I am we probably shouldn't have
gone I I we were still chatting about
what the top was and Rob's like by the
way we're live I hope you're all
yeah by the
way yeah galatis will never be done
right he'll be a cloud yeah because only
idiots would ever think of him as a
cloud just Fox will never get it right
Marvel would get it right but it'll be a
long time before they get it back so
it's like you know the question in the
chat was who's going to be the next
villain for Guardians of the Galaxy 2
I'm just trying to Vamp while it's
everything
CL in the reboot is that what you're
saying I think I love about the whole uh
Fox thing is that fox is refusing to
give it up like everyone now is like you
failed horribly just give it up do it
just do it they're like we might do a
Spiderwoman movie oh my God the fox The
Fox and the Sony thing they're just like
two petulant children who are like no I
know how this works and it's like no we
bought this 10 years ago yeah no you
broke it alone why do we all sound like
we're from
Jersey you know some people don't sound
like that from
Jersey the shore does how close are you
to the shore I'm like 45 minutes look at
my
poof H look at my
poof
what you know they they get the poof
hair thing Dave you said you weren't
on Jersey hair man this podcast is
descending into total Madness like
you're the one that launched us we're
still talking about Jersey Shore we're
just we're trying to keep things going
we're trying to keep the boat from
sinking yeah yeah so what what is your
current op on the politicals ofth K
North Korea how about that I mean I
think it's pretty much been stagnant
since like the 70s like it hasn't really
gone anywhere I mean like it sucks but
like North Korea is a non- entity I mean
it's become basically just a joke in the
International Community at this point
yeah it will be considered a joke until
they launch the nuclear strikes they're
not gonna launch Nuclear Strike they
don't have any I don't even I don't even
think Rob's messing with the anymore now
he's just loading his little tox they
say their army would starve in two weeks
yeah no they if they were to launch any
sort of conflict with any country no I
mean like yeah it really the question is
really like you've noticed that China
has kind of distanced itself from Korea
from North Korea and it's really like
their main backers at this point so like
even China is kind of like all right
well and without the full force of China
behind North Korea there's no way they
can actually sustain any kind of
viability in the I mean they can't
already but you know that's a good
discussion yeah North Korean
geop teia says he's hoping spiderverse
will save Spider-Man which reminds me I
should do a video on yeah oh you know
spiderverse coming out right yeah I
can't wait I just read uh Superior
number 32 the new Superior book oh it's
out oh yeah it came out today man after
this I gotta go pick up my books I told
you I caught up today so it's it's it's
it's tight man it's
fun okay
um this stream's G to drop out one more
time
oh I'm sorry guys I know I know how many
enemies can you make on our but yo Rob
check check the mic yo I think I thought
my mic was I thought it was louder
apparently it was just the I've got a uh
God I need to I need to figure out how
to get all my [__] together I've got a
do this at 10:30 next time just say I I
need to do something man like I have a
um I've got a converter a digital analog
converter and um it's like this little
icle thing it's what I plug my XLR mic
into and uh apparently that was turned
down so wait we have messages just so
you guys know this podcast is brought to
you by Loot Crate of comic story and no
one else has it but me so make sure you
click the link down below and
uh okay we should we should like we
should actually be a whole lot better
now I'll put my Loot Crate link down
there
video looks right good right now Benny
well not what my camera yeah yeah
actually looks pretty pretty uh HD right
there
con welcome to the weekly poll pre-show
brought to you by S Rob Dave and me and
for the record I've been told to stop
Hamming up the openings so we're going
to Super ham up the opening
oh man don't tell me what not to do
guys
okay we are back all well this is the
pre-show and we're changing it up this
time we are not going to do a verses
this time we're going to do something
for TV little house we're gon to do
whatever s wants to call it yeah I don't
know I I I maybe we could call it the
shoot back section I got nothing man I
don't we can call the Rob needs to get
his [__] together because yeah we can
call it the cluster Rob
the cluster [__] of the start of this
podcast um no I mean well we we'll come
up with a I'm sure a name Will present
itself that's usually what happens with
these kinds of things all all of the
mothers of the kids that were watching
the podcast now shut us
off just dropped the bomb for the record
Dave is not he thinks he's cool Dave is
lounging because he's still recovering
so we're lucky got him on camera yeah we
have Dave on camera he's got a sweet mic
and he's not gonna be moving up uh below
his uh his waist so his new nickname is
secret boner anyway moving forward yeah
we'll just call the show secret boner um
anyway the idea was uh rather than do a
versus this week we would do just a a
kind of like a back issues esque
conversation or a tangents type question
uh tangents is the like sister show to
my show back issues which is basically
just taking a autonomous conversation a
really random very nerdy uh in-depth
conversation and saying well let's just
see where this goes let's follow that
train of logic uh Dave posed a great
topic in the chat and I think why not
let's let's give it a shot let's see how
it go that we everybody in the uh show
is familiar with the character and if
you're not familiar in the chat uh one
of us will shoot a picture of the
character we're talking about but we're
thinking about talking about the the uh
I think the totem of advanced idea
mechanics himself the the uh the I don't
know is he an artificial intelligence is
he a bioorganic creature no no he's a
he's a person voice a character
modok modok the question is not does MO
would not would modok defeat Captain
America not can modok interface with
cerebro rather does modok have genitals
and if so can and does he use them uh I
will lead the discussion and we'll see
where we go um my question is yeah does
he have genitals my and I guess my first
question is for Rob was he created or is
he a guy uh I actually don't remember
know this if it's
accurate uh I believe they went through
his origin in The Avengers animated
series that was recently run yeah they
did and he was some
like some experiment that he did on
himself like some genetic experiment
that just made his head super huge and
shrunk the rest of his body yeah yeah
but answer this question officially I
didn't realize you were going to go with
to sell so save me for last cuz I have
your definitive answer that's proven by
Comics oh what his if if if yes or no he
does have genitals yes um I do know I do
have the answer is is there rule 34 with
modok no let's not find out but I do
know the answer to this I thought you
were gonna come with something else oh
cool well 34 in Google don't no 34 I
don't yeah I don't do not look up rule
30 for My Little Pony that was a very
bad night I
had Benny uh play Devil's advocat with
us for uh for the okay and you guys can
decide if this is valid or not because
the my point of reference may or may not
be valid fair enough but uh yeah so if
he was created by Advanced ID mechanics
I mean first of all we know modok stands
for
machine only wait no crap what is it
it's
it's is it machine or is it I don't know
man You' know better than I
would I've seen I've seen two comics
with modok and the first one was the uh
buildup the leadup to secret secret
Invasion so oh when they go when they go
into the cave and like that created that
was yeah that was written by Bendis he
doesn't know anything about what modok
is and I only say that because he
doesn't care okay here we go modok is a
mental organism designed only for
killing okay O Okay only designed for
killing uh so so in that case if he was
designed if he was created by Advanced
idea mechanics aim and it was only for
killing I think he does not have
genitals and the reason why I don't
think so that he could not use his
genitals as a weapon
I mean I mean like his his his whole
physical structure is is such that if he
were able to use his genitals for a
weapon it would not be in any
unconventional way it would be in the
way that a flasher uses his genitals as
a weapon to to upset and disturb
innocent passer by not necessarily as an
instrument of Destruction although he
does have mental Powers so maybe he uses
like some kind of maybe like psylock
psionic blade he has a pionic dong I
don't know uh gentlemen I'll I'll I'll
throw it to you what uh what's the
what's the deal with modok's junk I've
brought the evidence and you guys and
I'll show you the cover of the book and
you decide if if I'm alled to use this
okay
this is always a definitive source of
answer yeah oh
no wow he's just like a cube of
Flesh Deadpool discovers the current
situation Yeah by just took off to grab
that
comic people were like why is Vinnie's
chair empty like somebody then he came
back and he was like really super creepy
he did something with his left arm arm
that looked like he might have been
putting his hand down his pants no
actually I'll let you guys know my left
arm over here I'm fishing in a video
game right
now I mean I have the real sound in my
ear and every time I caught something
I'm hitting the
button that may be the sign of a problem
I need to dedicate some portion of my
brain to playing a game I'm not even
really playing it cognitively I just
need to be able to be occupying some
kind of space in my head for video
gaming um Deadpool the answer to
everything is the answer to everything I
agree with that Deadpool Deadpool is the
answer to everything wrong with Marvel
Comics yes well okay well I mean we
brought up this idea and Dave did put
that into the chat and the discussion
was we were I thought s was going to
come up with another one but would you
like me to definitively give you an
answer I think we have to unless rob you
have a unless Rob and Dave you have just
modok modok is one of those one of those
characters where he's so obscure that I
I mean I don't know like I don't I don't
know anything about the guy
man imagine if he was in the Cinematic
Universe exactly like that I mean a
floating Head shooting weird that would
be shooting mind bombs of people I don't
know okay right now modok in the
universe is in the computer that Captain
America and Scar Scarlet Witch yeah uh
Black Widow found right no that's um
that's I'm not huge America no that's uh
yeah he's the guy that normally has the
giant TV in his chest yeah he's he's an
actual character yeah he has a he has a
a physical body and a TV I thought that
was modok myself the whole time I'm not
a huge like you know uh I'm not a huge
Captain America buff so okay yeah he's
not a Captain America I think in order
to Bone up on everything that happened
to Captain America you'd really only
have to read you'd have to like it would
take like an hour to become an Act
Captain America like expert yeah um but
yeah so as stated in Deadpool okay which
is a which is a definitive resource for
anything in the Marvel Universe
practically the Bible of the Marvel um
in this particular run of Deadpool which
is Dracula's Gauntlet he is currently
trying to take Dracula's uh future bride
to meet him and and seal the deal with
the vampires but as we know in the
current timeline and continuity of
Deadpool he ends up marrying Dracula's
bride and has crazy adventures with her
by himself she eventually teams up with
the dazzler and they go and they go back
in time to the 1970s to kill disco
vampires so anyway back to this
story um there is a period in here in
which he he has to fight
modok right here okay he shows up he
modok shows up to stop Dracula's bride
he's
been okay now in standard Deadpool
fashion
Deadpool
basically uses some funky technology
that he discovered to remove modock from
the chair oh wow wow
okay now by removing him from the chair
we discover through standard Deadpool
humor that there is a functioning toilet
in the chair
oh so we know that modok has an anus
he's got an ass it's a toilet well he's
a mutant like he was created from a
regular guy yes so assuming he still has
male anatomy then we discover he has the
entire male anatomy still because they
have to use a forklift to get him out of
there and they accuse dead Cole of
injuring a handicapped man
wow um a profoundly disabled man has had
his wheelchair stolen by
Deadpool wow okay um that that is that
is a perfect Deadpool comic is what
that that is that is Deadpool divining
defining comic book that's exactly what
that is
as our as our debate judge right is that
our definitive answer to I mean like if
it's in a Marvel comic and it takes
place in the 616 continuity I think I
got to give it to him yeah well yes
because that because this leads into
Dead's wedding which had every character
at it and yeah yeah but all the all the
Marvel events have that like storm got
married and that happened and yeah I
mean that every time characters get
married that happens but yeah I think uh
unless Rob since you are uh Marvel
Comics explained I think uh I think we
got to give it to him I think I mean I
don't I've never taken the time to learn
anything about modok so I mean bny bny
could very well have designed that comic
last night and I would know any
different I would be like all right yeah
I I mean like the only thing that really
left it questioning for me was he's
designed only for killing he's not
designed for killing and also having sex
or also peeing so I thought maybe he
might not have junk but that's the thing
is you can only do so much designing
somebody from from a regular man well
yeah but you can like scale it back you
can Human Centipede it up and actually
like that would actually be a really
interesting like Marvel Max take on
modok is that like so is that the aim
scientists captured this poor man from
Banger M and said you're going to be our
MCH our mental organism designed only
for killing and you will not have any
genitals because that is the rule yeah
well you need to be focused I need you
to be focused on only killing so why
then why give him a toilet well other I
don't know well because he still needs
nutrients he still needs to process you
know nutrition state that he has a to so
he has well because you you did not you
said does he have functioning genitals
you did not say functioning genitals for
reproduction no no no no it's true
functioning genitals requires a toilet
well part of the question was how how
can he use them yeah like does he use
them does he use them I mean I would
hope so like Optimus Brown so um now we
have our answer about his junk yes and a
Deadpool comic no less the one place you
would expect to find the question of
whether or not a character can actually
use their genitals it's a Deadpool comic
and I really am not surprised to know
that that's that's where the answer is
found are you more surprised to know
that I have it right here surprised have
that cop you remember that like just to
go I'm actually yeah I'm surprised that
you actually have that like like I knew
where to go to find out whether or not
modok had last night I went through like
a three-hour stint of catching up on all
my books and I went through all the
Deadpool gauntlets and I remember
reading that going that is so
awesome I did that with Infinity
Gauntlet the other day no it was sitting
on my pile of things to board and bag
that's why I was
like I was actually doing okay ahead oh
no go ahead man I was gonna say I was
doing a live I was doing a back issues
in the car with my girlfriend the other
day talking about Infinity Gauntlet I
was like oh well Infinity Gauntlet and
I'm explaining it we're just
like okay m did you see the new Avengers
issue where they explain that the The
Infinity Gauntlet being destroyed
because they used it to stop the
incursions but the ultimate universe
that has a alternate version of the
Justice League has their own version of
The Infinity Gauntlet and it's the prism
cube with prism
mirrors no I didn't I don't read new
Avengers anymore Hickman pushed me away
and and to follow up before we go to the
real weekly pool podcast to follow up
our JLA versus The Avengers discussion
yeah the Avengers destroyed J Clon oh
yeah like we're just now getting into
the podcast after like 45 minutes of
technical
difficulties well here's the kicker
here's the kicker Rob because you of all
people will appreciate how The Avengers
defeated the JLA clones okay Doctor
Strange sold his soul to the devil and
then pretty much eradicated everyone's
Soul which is totally
unnecessary yeah because Doctor Strange
could just snap his fingers and the
entire conflict ends he wasn't strong
enough yep oh I don't believe that one I
don't believe that one bit Str he sold
his soul and he sucked the souls out of
the J and they you know that's the one
thing that you can just use to explain
anything away it's magic yep well that's
why Doctor Strange was see that's the
problem with Doctor Strange like like
Doctor Strange showed up in the comics
and he was like oh super powerful I can
do anything and then Marvel was just
like all right this guy's way
overpowered and so they just like
powered him down like there was a point
where he lost his powers because he
refused to fight him the on behalf of
the vashanti then he gave they were less
than they were before I mean really he's
running off to grab another
comic hey guys let me let me go to Steak
and Shake and get a milkshake real quick
yeah we're gonna get some you not been
holding it every episode this entire
time and I could just get up and go
whenever
I but um but that that was the problem
like Doctor Strange he he was depowered
more or less and a lot of people hated
the idea that doctor strange was
depowered hated the idea that he was not
as powerful as he used to be because he
was he was like a niche character mhm
JLA clones yep as a matter of fact
Squadron Supreme yeah something like
that and they actually call the Batman
character Wayne that's his name first
name is that like a newer comic that
looks like the newer Avengers logo it is
it is episode of new or issue of new no
no the most recent issue is here when
Neymar destroys everything but yeah well
yeah
uh hold on hold on I want to is that 20
that's 19 ah 20 is the issue where it
happens but Doctor Strange goes evil so
yeah yeah it's he goes evil every they
don't even know what to do remember when
World War Hulk where he like absorbed
the spirit of the dark and you're like
come on like he was just so pissed off
and he still couldn't beat Hulk he was
he Hulk I've got so much rage I'm trying
to control it and like he just couldn't
control it and Hulk just beat the [__]
out of him yeah brushed his hands and
then kicked his ass it was just it was
pretty funny God
World enough time to get angry guys
we're moving to the real podcast so wait
welcome to the weekly
poll that's all I'm going to do I'm not
going to do it there's no do the whole
thing okay we've been talking for 30
minutes you was told not to ham it up
and we're wel to the weekly poll I'm
coming story and that's the guy from TB
little house uh that's Rob I don't know
his name uh and uh there there is a
secret boner we're good to go secret
boner secret boners okay so secret boner
so Guardians of the Galaxy just came out
and this is the first time we've all
actually had a chance to get together to
talk about them that's true so what did
everybody think because I saw your all's
reviews the Galaxy I'm just I'm
just I've rethought stck in this room
for the last two weeks oh God in a
here's everything that happens in
Guardians of the
Galaxy basically Point by point every
twist every turn every character change
here it is for you I like it but I
didn't like the amount of changes they
made to the continuity as a matter of
fact I'm going to make a video going
over the differences because they they
basically said we have the Guardians of
the Galaxy no one has any idea who this
is we got a talking raccoon a talking
tree and a bunch of cool guys that
everyone's going to love like Chris
Pratt so you know what just rewrite
everything so it functions in a single
movie that we don't need to do any
explanations for yep yeah works for me I
mean it's it was it was tracks got
completely Rewritten I was about dumb
idiot who's hilarious go over his head
popular Breakaway characters in that
movie works for me I I love the
reinvention and that's just it I love
all of the reinventions I love what they
did with the movie yeah but they went so
far from The Source material oh yeah
it's not even funny I'm honestly
debating oh and real quick real quick
spoil a warning if you don't want to
yeah yeah people are people okay don't
don't spoil anything yeah don't ruin it
for day yeah we're only we're only a
week out so I I bet about half the
people that are watching haven't seen it
yet like a topic because we can't talk
an hour about Guardians of the
Galaxy I guess okay then we can postpone
damn it man I really want to talk about
this well here you know what building on
Guardians of the Galaxy I had heard a
rumor that there was going to be um
sakarin in the movie I saw Zero
sakarin yeah uh sakarin for those of you
who don't know they're the native race
of beings that are from the planet that
the world war Hulk is or I'm sorry
Planet
Hulk they're like insects no they're
like no they're like big strong they're
strong humanoid people I mean like like
every an like every creature in the
Marvel Universe they look like people
that was that was one of the creatures
that Hulk actually married wasn't it she
was she was a chick that was killed
during the whole time he marries the old
strong okay hold on how about this let's
all give our spoiler free opinions okay
and will you will promise in two weeks
we will have a total nitpick spoiler
crazy
episode that gives everyone three weeks
to watch The Guardians movie and
honestly right now do I mean the history
of the Guardians of Galaxy is cool they
change a lot of it yes but it's in a
good way that's my opinion I loved the
movie so I side with that I side with
that yeah
agreed they didn't change anything in a
drasic manner like Amazing Spider-Man
nothing crazy like that where you're
just like this is stupid it also wasn't
crappily made like amazing spider oh my
God yeah I mean okay okay here's I was I
was okay with Amazing Spiderman amazing
Spiderman was a welcome can we remove
Dave from the podcast his opinion is now
null and void I will say it's a welcome
change after seeing Spider-Man 3 at the
mid I was yeah it was much better on a
side note with Amazing Spider-Man
Actually I didn't mind it because they
are just completely Reinventing it yeah
as long as we agree that that's
happening I'm fine with it if we try to
compare it to the story lines then it's
just what the hell you literally
butchered it you literally butchered
Spider-Man you are literally Hitler
here's a problem here was a problem with
Amazing Spider-Man like I didn't give a
[__] about like GW Stacy dying I was
like oh well here we go she falls and
then he shoots his webbing and then she
hits her head and I was like I don't
care because I didn't care about her
character there was no character
development there didn't agree with the
ending that blew my [__] mouth like I
thought they could have cut like 10
minutes off of the movie and had it
ending with him debating if he was going
to be Spider-Man still or not because of
what happened yeah and some little kid
running out in front of rhino like oh
I'm G to be like man this is so stupid I
was like this is the dumbest thing that
I've ever seen not to mention that Rhino
gives that kid like 15 minutes for
Spider-Man to show up when he's not even
wanting Spider-Man to show up really
yeah he because he's a pawn of the
Sinister 6 he was asked to be there to
draw Spider-Man clearly that was all an
orchestration by this [__] movie
that we going to make about the Sinister
6 ryo's a pawn they asked him to go out
there and Razzle up the crowd and get
Spider-Man to come back so they could
get revenge on him it's so stupid I
think Sony just saw Marvel oh yeah like
like doing the end credit scenes and
like getting people excited with them
yep and then they were like we're gonna
have like six things yeah no but okay
here's here's the biggest gripe I have
with that Gwen Stacy deal not only did
we get no Pro pop development from her
not only did it just happen out of the
blue with no real warning or anything
like literally Green Goblin just shows
up you're like oh great fight scene and
now we're going to go check out Norman
cool in my opinion they ruined the
impact of it because Spider-Man in the
comics kills Gren Stacy because he
improperly uses his webbing yeah and he
learns that he has to be more careful he
can't just do what he wants willy-nilly
no she was already dead when he showed
up in the movie he catches her too late
and she hits her head on the ground that
doesn't show us that he doesn't on the
ground yeah she smacks in the ground she
cracks her neck yeah I could have sworn
that she hit it and she like
bounced no she she cracks her neck it's
just like the comic in that he pulls her
he catches her but his webbing gives
just enough for her to like snack hit
ground no I think it's her neck snapping
well they show her head hit in the
ground and there's three people here who
saw it a different way and in my opinion
well no I'm not even arguing about that
I mean he maybe a dis Snapp her neck but
what I'm saying is the general public is
going to see her just hitting her head
and say that's what happened and in my
opinion that ruins him learning how to
use his powers properly that just shows
I was too slow that's the old Superman
conundrum of I can't be everywhere at
once right yeah no I thought I thought
in the comics
um that Gwen Stacy was already dead when
Peter Parker got to her like like the
Green Goblin was like taunting him and
he was like she was dead before you even
showed
up he has this giant like generic like
super villain scene where he's like I'm
going to throw her off the side and then
he throws her off the side yeah and he
catches her SNS her neck C neck and then
and then Green Goblin says you fool she
was dead the fall alone killed her like
okay she was dead before you hit her
with the webbing which by the way in
Spectacular Spider-Man Paul Jenkins in
like the late 90s Rett conned in there's
a scene where Norman Osborne is like
cackling and talking to himself and he's
like I told him that she was dead while
she was full you can't just die from
falling from a great height she didn't
fall that far no Peter Parker killed
Gwen Stacy there's no doubt in my mind
that he killed her like and and pretty
much everyone but Peter Parker agrees
that Spider-Man killed Gwen Stacy like
and yeah yeah no like that that's one of
the Stables of the character now I mean
that and the Uncle Ben thing yeah did
you know that actually uh part of the
one more day retcon in addition to
undoing the marriage um re singling
Peter Parker giving him his web shooters
back and bringing Harry Osborne back
from the dead they were actually talking
about bringing Gwen Stacy back from yeah
that's what I'd heard about that like
people were pissed because it was Peter
Parker's motivation to like to do
everything that he's done at like up to
this point to be like an actual
superhero yeah because he he suffered
like like Uncle Ben was one thing
because Uncle Ben was his in action but
for him like he tried to save Ginn Stacy
and he couldn't save her and so he
learns well he learns that with he
learns the first lesson with great power
comes great responsibility I must act as
Spider-Man but then he learns after G
Stacey dies like that's not enough yeah
right like I need like he matures it's
like learning right from wrong and then
learning the gray areas of morality when
you get into like your 20s and 30s like
it's it's just a great once again
Spider-Man's just a great allegory for
go for growing up it was another stage
it was that point when Peter Parker was
kind of being in was was was getting his
feet wet in college so like he's
maturing it was just another microcos or
a macrocosm of his you know mature his
maturation it was really like the def
one of like one of most pivotal moments
in Spider-Man's history I would argue
he's only had like three pivotal moments
in his history and like that's one of
them the rest of it all window dressing
like Venom no Venom's a character and it
was neat but it didn't change who the
character was no nothing came out of
that yeah like there are things that
happen to Spider-Man since then but
there are very few pivotal moments where
the character grows and Chang yeah and
that's that's what that's to me what's
interesting about Spider-Man is because
you go back to the comics and you you
physically watch him progress as a
character like he's he's a teenager and
he uses his powers for Mischief like
that's how he starts out yeah I mean he
he pulls pranks ons in the cafeteria
yeah I mean the first thing he does like
and catching all the the food no one saw
that well I mean like literally like the
first thing he does when he gets his
powers is he gets revenge on Flash
Thompson yeah that's like the first
thing he does in the comics yep he
doesn't save anybody he doesn't go stop
bank and being robbed or save a cat from
a tree like he goes and gets r Flash
Thompson well his first well his first
action is with yeah no when his what
like you mean an Amazing Fantasy 15 or
do you mean like Amazing Spider-Man
number one no um Amazing Fantasy number
15 I thought that was his first action
oh that was his first action I'm trying
to remember like he gets his powers uhuh
I mean I think his
first I want I want to get us back on a
pseudo track there are we gonna discuss
because just you guys know the plot for
the podcast today plot yeah the
discussion was going to be Guardians of
the Galaxy but you're all right the
movie's too new we don't want you all to
just not let's not ruin Guardians for
you but that now we need to decide
something to talk about so is it are we
going to talk about Amazing Spider-Man I
mean I'm fine with that we don't have to
I don't want us to do 45 minutes tangent
of Amazing Spider-Man then Rob's like
now we're gonna talk about the
topic well I was trying to find Amazing
Fantasy I don't have Amazing Fantasy
number 15 I have everything Spider-Man
except for that one we discuss
Spider-Man I got this because while
we're discussing this the comment what
do you want to see us discuss about
today yeah I'm said our plan was
Guardians of the Galaxy Guardians of the
Galaxy really good
point see it and half of you guys didn't
see
it with this Amazing Fantasy discussion
oh tell us you want to know about we can
talk about the direction that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is leading
to no you don't even need to see
Guardians of the Galaxy to know that
Marvel's moving towards the guardians
Guardians I think is gonna change the I
think Guardians kind of changed Marvel's
game I think that it emboldens them even
further to do to take more risks and try
new things
so like I think that whatever they had
planned they're going to do but they're
just going to go balls out with it like
as like with Ant-Man they're going to be
like as opposed to when when when Edgar
Wright left Ant-Man and they were like
so we're making Ant-Man uh here's a
really horrible director who's going to
do it and let's kind of downplay it a
little bit at first they were like Edgar
Wright Ant-Man Paul Rudd Michael Douglas
it's gonna be awesome Ant-Man and then
Guardians of the Galaxy came out or was
coming out and they were like they kind
of downplaying Ant-Man and they were
like cuz Edgar right left and they're
like yeah and there's some bad uh news
about it but now that Guardians worked
and it shows that Marvel can allow
directors to have their own creative
freedom and Edgar Wright really just
left because at the World's End was a
really bad movie that um he that like
Marvel will allow the creators to have
that kind of control and so I think
they're going to be like let's go with
it let's gonna make let's make Ant-Man
and we're gonna you know sell it when
you say at the World's End is about are
you talking about Pirates of the
Caribbean no I'm sorry I meant uh I
meant the Third Sean Edgar Wright Shawn
pan or okay okay okay Simon Peg and Nick
Frost movie okay I was like wants us to
talk about Amazing Spider-Man
2 it's I I mean we can keep talking
about Amazing Spider-Man 2 and I'm down
with like bashing on that movie I'm okay
with that I just I I didn't want to
spend an hour of bashing on it and then
we're like so what's on the podcast
today yeah yeah I agree I agree that's
all I didn't want to do I mean I'm fine
with going on about that um so I mean we
could do this Q&A style so
B better until we come back to that
what's our opinion on DC and Marvel
hating marriages well I think Mar think
Marvel hates marriages Marvel pioneered
marriages in comic books Fantastic 4 was
the first group to get married in Marvel
Comics you have uh you have Mary Jane
Watson you have Peter Parker you got
Quicksilver and uh Crystal from the
Inhumans I mean you've got multiple
marriages that take place over Marvel
first comic book gay marriage in Marvel
was that Northstar uh yeah yeah yeah I
mean Marvel's been really Progressive in
terms of marriages I don't think Marvel
hat the most was uh DC jumping on the
gay marriage bandwagon yeah and then
going oh oh the Earth two Green Lantern
he's gay yeah look look at this
one
remember yeah but but they also didn't
say Earth two so F story about the whole
gay marriage thing one of my biggest
superheroes I love The Flash and Green
Lantern the most right yep so my my
comic book store knows I'm a huge fan of
Green Lantern so the announcement comes
out and they know it's Earth two they
know it but the announcement comes out
Green Lantern is gay
I walk in like how do you feel about
that gay Green Lantern what you about
gay Green Lantern Benny and I'm like oh
my God it's it's her two like no no DC
says Green Lantern's gay maybe it's how
Jordan
secretly I mean it's like like nobody
gives a [__] like nobody cares that
character nobody cared when that
happened either there was more hoopla
about the Northstar marriage because
that was a couple that had been together
for a while they weren't recently regret
con yeah they were a gay couple that
that's what it was yeah Marvel makes a
big deal out of marriages and their
Comics like
storm storm and tala yeah storm storm
and black panther got married and Marvel
put the entire Civil War V on hold just
to show the marriage in that comic also
UND it like they undid it like in
between panels yes they did well don't I
mean see now of the high priest and old
our marriage but you're the high priest
get
out like you just ruined how how great
the marriage was I
appreciate gonna do a silk movie what oh
yeah that's probably the movie silk
here's the question because of the thing
now Marvel uh Sony owns all Spider-Man
stuff right and they want to make a
Spiderwoman movie and all that other
crap yeah do they have the rights to
Silk yeah because silk is a new creation
yeah but it's yeah but like I bet uh
slot will probably get like a percentage
as opposed to like if if silk were if
silk were created in 1968 no uh the fact
that she's made now and that it's like
you know just like if they were to use
antivenom I think that slot would
probably get some kind of residual
so you're think because she's been
introduced in Spider-Man Sony still owns
her
yeah I don't know who silk is I doubt oh
s She was recently introduced an Amazing
Spider-Man um she's apparently the girl
who also got bit by the same spider that
Peter Parker got bit by yeah and she's
been like under lock and key this whole
time yeah yeah it's it's a stupid it's a
stupid attempt at Marvel to try to
recreate a new spider girl it's just a
disaster and she hasn't even been here
for more than an issue and it's just
like I don't
I mean that that's the problem like
Marvel will come up with these gimmicks
every once in a while like Marvel will
come along and they'll say okay we need
a new spider girl like how can we make
it's like you got seven of them you got
seven pick one and change it yeah so
they like they
still yeah they at Target and see which
one hits the bullseye I mean you've got
you've got like Felicia Hardy as black
hat you've got Jessica Drew as Spider
Girl you've got Julia or Julie whatever
her name is Julie Parker being
reintroduced to this to the universe
Madam web now she's Madam Webb now yeah
yeah Craven's family killed the original
Madam Webb and the the Web of Life re
weaved another Madam web and made
Spiderwoman AKA Arachne AKA Julia
Carpenter into the new Madam web so she
went blind but also became psychic and
so she's like a state so she's like a
single mom and and a Madam web so she
like kind of guides Spider-Man through
like the mystical bull [__] of Marvel
Universe man I that she is actually kind
of fun I like the idea I wish there was
a spider I wish there was a mad and Web
book because the scenes we get of her
where she's like she's she can see the
future but she cannot say she I don't
think she can physically actually tell
you literally what's going to happen
without making it some kind of riddle
yeah no no because isn't that what
happened with uh the whole Spectacular
Spider-Man she warned him of superior
Spider-Man yep she did and cuz he even
he even says oh she warned me of this
crap yep she says uh you after spider
Island you got Kane the you you don't
have to be Spider-Man anymore you can
take this like anti-venom serum and make
it go away and he's like no I have to be
Spider-Man she goes well I'm sorry for
your death that's coming
like and uh yeah like but they also show
you like she's a single mom she lives in
New York her kids like 11 or 12 and like
that would be a fun story like I think
it'd be a really cool book like about a
a woman who has psychic powers that
can't act that can see the future but
can't tell anybody without making it
into some [__] riddle like and being
a mom like you know you're like you know
your kid is going to go into danger
today but you don't know what it's going
to be and you can't warn her you have to
let her that's that's neat that would be
really crappy I me it would be oh it
would be crappy but like you know you
you'd see her kind of like reaping what
she SWS so to speak you'd see her like
kind of like being challenged on like
she can it out to Spider-Man like oh I'm
sorry for the tragedy that's coming but
like when it comes to her own daughter
she's going to be like I'm going to do
whatever it takes I'm going to I'm going
to cheat and steal and lie and like
force this psychic [__] to work out for
my and it's going to like be
self-fulfilling like that that that has
least you know St Marvel's always
talking about story potential that is
that is story potential right there but
they're like no also it it makes it into
a female character that they could sell
and Market yeah without making Thor into
a woman yeah but they're not gonna do
that because they have Thor they have
Thor as a chick they have lady Thor
which is has it come out who is it's
gonna we haven't learned yet it's I
still say it's gonna come out of
whatever happens in original sin yep I
agree the way it's lined up um okay so
follow up they said the new FID 2 got
rid of all marriages yep so they did
yeah they get rid of every single
marriage but but this is a good question
for Rob do you think that we're gonna
see Adam Warlock in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yeah do not watch the Guardians
of the
Galaxy I mean yes yes the answer to that
question is we will most definitely see
Adam Warlock in the Marvel Cinematic un
there is no doubt in my mind but will we
see how you could do Infinity Gauntlet
without see you can't do Infinity
Gauntlet without Adam Warlock yeah I
mean you have like Adam Warlock is the
leader of the opposite side of Thanos
and Infinity Gauntlet it's like all of
Adam warlock's
forces what Captain America is gonna
step up yeah man Captain America dude
Captain America like there's there's a
point in The Infinity Gauntlet when
they're fighting on the giant you
know yeah that Thanos Made In Space the
big Shrine and like Captain America's
like the last man standing and like he
walks up to Thanos Thanos is like a foot
taller than he is and then he just gets
totally demolished I'm like you're
talking about a guy that turned Nova
into blocks and turn Thor into like a
giant like crystal statue yep so like
what's Captain America really going to
do I mean sure is going to be useless so
he's got an indomitable Spirit Well
everybody's useless up against was a
complete wash it was man like I mean it
was he just be he just the only reason
Thanos lost The Infinity Gauntlet is
because he just got careless yeah well
that's the idea the thing is is the
reason he lost it was he made himself
completely deprived of
SE
sensory he made himself one he made
himself one with the universe is what it
was so so uh the chat is saying that
James gun has already stated he's
bringing a new members to the Guardians
of the Galaxy in the sequel and they
think that that's how we're gonna get
Adam Warlock that's what the chat say
yeah that's no spoilers that's that's
just all rumors um and the next question
well what do you think of that real
quick do you think he'll be the new
member of the Guardians oh yeah uh you
don't think he will be I don't think
they're GNA use him I think he if they
if they do use him he'll be in like
Guardians 3 I don't think they're gonna
use him I yeah because we have too many
rotating cast members in the current
Guardians book oh that they could very
easily shoehorned Angela Iron Man the
Guardians of the Galaxy I don't see Iron
Man but they could easily do Angela
could do Venom If he if he takes off as
a breakout member in the comic series
which I don't see him doing right now
but they could use him they could
because of the whole symbiot thing no
they couldn't use Venom they'd have
they'd have to give a whole new plot to
it but they definitely could use Angela
and she's becoming like she's almost
been brought into the universe to be put
into the Guardians right now that seems
to be kind of why she's here it's lame
like it's weird like I mean I don't
think I think we'll see Adam Warlock on
the Guardians before we see Angela in
the movies and I will my statement I
think she I think I think we probably
see Adam Warlock at least in Guardians 2
as a as an actor like so here he may
make an appearance I mean we we've had
the collector for like three movies now
collector oh God D don't do not diss The
Collector collector is an awesome I just
I was like all right like you know what
I like to I like the collector better in
the Guardians movie than I did in the in
the bonus scene uh all right guys in in
the in the Marvel Comics The Collector
shows up and the first thing he does is
he captures wasp it's like Avengers
issue number 28 or something like that
he captures wasp with a jar like that's
literally how he captured her and the
jar is just like sitting on top of her
in like his domain and he's like now I
want to get all the Avengers and like he
goes in this quest to try to capture all
the Avengers like The Collector I agree
is not nearly as interesting in the
comics as he is in the movie so far like
I thought he was a lot more interesting
in the movie than he was in the in the
comics but that's like the collector is
exactly what it is like he's an elder of
the universe he's a member of the oldest
race in the universe so yeah hold I'm
I'm going to veto any discussions about
the collector because he is The
Guardians movie and I don't want to go
okay so next question then next question
okay that Benny huh we didn't we didn't
say he was in The Guardians movie but
now said he was interesting in the movie
and he didn't like the bonus scene so if
you put two and two together yeah he's
also I mean you know he's in the movie
yeah you the previous right right well
let's stop it there he's in the movie
congratulations you've established that
so um the next question is they asked me
what my favorite Marvel crossover was
but I'd like to get everyone's opinion
after I gave out mine but honestly I
liked Avengers versus X-men I've read
all of them but I like that one the most
because it's smashing grab it's awesome
fight scenes followed up by a complete
ending there's no real major loose plot
threads and it was a major changing
event to the Marvel universe that
actually still is being talked about
today you know it's something that has
has had ramifications for years
following the event and this isn't
something like you know like a of vol
we've forgotten all about at this point
original sin could very easily be pushed
under the rug at this point it's nothing
humongous has happened in it yet yeah
but Avengers versus X-men was just a big
like it was almost like a popcorn movie
of fights followed up with a with a
massive Universe changing event they had
a they had a whole series of that comic
run called versus which was literally
only fight just the fights yeah exactly
so but that's my opinion but what are
you guys what is your favorites what are
your favorite crossovers well I can tell
you my favorite is not Avengers versus
X-men yeah I hated Avengers versus X-men
Marvel Marv guys Marvel advertised that
and said hey guys the Phoenix force is
coming back and I was like oh sweet
maybe they'll bring back Jean Gray
because if there's any character I want
to see come back it's
Jean I mean the marketing in the name
was [__] that Summers Hope Summers is
not Jean Gray no you get the young
version you got the Young no I'm talking
about Jean Gray like I'm talking about
Chris claremont's Phoenix dark Phoenix
run they don't like her anymore she's
been more interesting dead than she ever
was alive they're never
use but Emma is way more fun to write
for even I mean you're right because
even the new Jing gray they're
completely rewriting like everything
about her power sets and all that stuff
which tells you that the original Jean
Gray was boring Rob she was
boring love the the original Jean Gray
was never boring the original gr was
amazing but anyway so Marvel says the
Phoenix force is coming back and I was
like cool you know I'm this is going to
be kind of cool the Phoenix force shows
up somebody or a group of people usually
get wrecked and then the Phoenix Force
goes away so the Phoenix force shows up
and says hey you know I'm going to be
destroyed more or less and then I'm
going to split into five different
people and I was like oh my god really
so we've got five people running around
with the Phoenix Force's Powers I
thought that Marvel was I thought that
the writers of Marvel were sitting
around and saying how can we bring the
Phoenix Forks back and make it
interesting and then they ran into a
roadblock and they said well let's just
split it up among five people and see
what happens and I was like man this is
it's it's awful I guarantee you that
that idea of splitting it into five
pieces that was there from the get-go
you think so gue you I I can hear
thatman what I like about Avenger versus
xman though is the fact that the
ramifications have stayed because every
other crossover event normally gets
retconned or goes back to status quo
within six months yeah and Avengers
versus X-men kept me reading the whole
way through yes it's not quite as oh my
God as some of the other events that
that have happened you know Annihilation
is amazing the the stuff that's
happening in original sin is amazing
there's a lot of there's a lot of more
stories that are beefier in the actual
story yeah but what I like about
Avengers versus X-men is we haven't just
brought back Charles Xavier freed
Cyclops of all of murder charges and
just said it's over we're still dealing
with it but it's like two years later
and we're still dealing with it that's
why I like it yeah Civil War stuck
around for a good long time
unfortunately uh I thought Civil War was
fun but the only problem I have a civil
war is it got too convoluted too many
science too many books I thought Civil
War was just poorly written uh I don't
and too many characters acted out of
character oh that's I mean yeah too many
characters just acted in a certain way
just to make it work for that story okay
I think you guys are 100% wrong about
Civil War I thought Civil War was
spectacular and Civil War Frontline had
some of the best storytelling I've ever
seen in Marvel Civil War Front Line was
was was really clever and it was handled
maturely yeah I thought that's what I
will say about War Front Line but yeah
but House of M is Rob's favorite they're
saying it right now no no house House of
M is my second favorite storyline in
Marvel all she do is talk about house
ofm and and mad Jim Jaspers the Crooked
World story line yeah that was that was
a cool one um no my favorite my number
one favorite is the Age of Apocalypse
that is probably the one of the greatest
crossover events in Marvel Comics but
the the problem yeah the problem with
age of that was back before Marvel was
like okay let's have Main Events and
then let's have tie-ins Marvel was just
like here's a [__] ton of comics at are
Age of Apocalypse sorted out your good
luck it was
like Avengers disassemble it actually
gets coherent into like solid plots
that's yeah so anything before that is
good like Days of Future Past but it's
it's gone too quickly in my opinion yeah
yeah and same thing for DC DC didn't get
real serious about anything until like
the 2000s everything just was like oh
back to normal back to normal status how
quick can we fix
it no one in the comics mentions Age of
Apocalypse ever no you know no one no no
they mentioned the the X-Men from Days
of Future Past oh no those X-Men from
Days of Future Past are back to [__]
with us you know yeah I mean it's and
another thing is the the way things
happen there's only a few characters
that even knew Age of Apocalypse
happened yeah no and the time travel um
yeah there was there was Nate gray
because at the end of Age of Apocalypse
apocalypse is killed he's torn in half
by Magneto um the universe starts to
implode in on itself and I think Nate
gray X-Man escapes into the Earth 616
Dimension um dark Beast makes it into
the Earth 616 Dimension he actually he's
actually masquerading as Beast during
the entire Onslaught storyline which is
he's around right now you know that
right dark Beast is still dark Beast is
back he's an all new X-Men
really Xavier's son is mind controlling
dark beast and [__] with him and
making him feel feel guilty for bringing
the all new X-Men I thought they killed
off Legion I thought they like killed
him off entirely yeah me too like Gone
Forever which one which one's Legion
Legion Professor X's son that like time
no no oh the one that looks like
Professor X
yeah no in the in the 90s Legion was the
one that had the huge flat top he had
the tall hair he I'm not talking
Professor okay if you're not reading all
new X-Men right now we discovered that
Professor X has a son
um he has two sons couple Sons yeah God
man son so Professor X had a son with
Mystique Mystique also had a son with
Wolverine and those two sons are now
going back in time to try and kill off
the the new X-Men because they're trying
to get revenge on Xavier and a whole
another plot but there every time they
come back we kill them or remove them or
put them in jail but they've got a plan
they have a way where if they don't
change the future someone in the
timeline sends that message to the
future so now they know how to go back
in time and not do what [__] up yeah
it's a to time travel you're confused
thing see I hate that's that's why I
hate it when they use time travel like
that like legion's use of time travel
was the very least intelligent like
Legion was crazy he had multiple they're
really intelligent about this the the
rule is they go okay so Professor X's
son who looks just like Professor X
right now um he has mind controlled
Deadpool in the future um uh the Mary
something she's no that I really gave a
crap about um they've mind controlled um
a couple other characters but he's
controlling them and forcing them to go
back in time with him and he goes back
in time to kill off Jean Gray because
she's the only thing that will prevent
him from conquering and ruling the X-Men
he's trying to get revenge on the X-Men
because they killed off Professor X they
they killed off his dad and since he
didn't have a dad he grew up all evil
and crazy but their plan is every time
that they fail they they make notes
about it so in the future they like it
always cuts Back to the Future after
they get caught and you see them all
making their plans they get a letter and
the letter says and then normally it's
the Wolverine son he's like oh no we're
not doing that it doesn't work we're try
try a new plan you know yeah no but but
like what I'm saying is I'm talking
about like the writer's use in terms of
like the story of time travel see like
Legion was cool legion was crazy he had
like Jack Wayne and he had all these
weird personalities and stuff and his
argument was I can spare my dad all this
Misery by going back in time and killing
Magneto and he attempts to do that and
Xavier jumps in the way time travel you
know the whole universe changes and apoc
sees the whole thing time travel yeah
and at the at the end of at the end of
Legion Quest it's one of the coolest
scenes at the end of Legion Quest
apocalypse is standing there and he was
like my time has come or something like
that and then it just starts out with
with the Age of Apocalypse s like I mean
that was a problem like it just picks up
with Age of Apocalypse it's just there
all of a sudden and then you actually
get the backstory of what happened as
time goes on when you learn about
apocalypse launch forces to take over
the world North America stuff like that
but the Age of Apocalypse was so cool
because you have like Avalon which is
like the Safe Haven for humans and
mutants you've got like um uh Juggernaut
who's a monk you have um you still have
like William Striker and the purifiers
but now they're like henchmen of
Apocalypse you have uh like Destiny I
mean you have like all these really like
all the characters are alive for the
most part they're just playing different
roles and that was a difference like the
Days of Future Past like everybody's
dead and there's like a handful of
characters so Hand wavy where they're
like oh and everyone all the Avengers
were killed yeah yeah they're just like
they're all gone I mean about apocalypse
versus Days of Future Past future is
that we still reference Days of Future
Past future those X-Men keep coming back
in time to make sure it doesn't happen a
d of apocalpse just went away in regard
and honestly time travel just makes
everything convoluted and confusing I
just watched the back issues over at TV
little house where pretty much the
entire episode is his two guys going why
that doesn't work with time travel that
was flasho though that was much more
lazy
than yeah I was trying to understand
that video science seems a lot
more dumb than
Marvel yeah
Marvel like that's what what my problem
with with final crisis was and I know I
talk about that a lot but they were just
like this happens because of sciency
things let's move on now yeah yeah yeah
I mean I know I skimmed over a couple
things in final crisis but that's pretty
much how it all happened yeah oh uh
Superman can build a wish makak machine
don't question it he just he went feut
and saw how it good how it work how it
works build a wish making machine he did
build a wish and he's Sayang Dark Side
to death like I mean I I you know it's
like not all the stories that involve
time travel are terrible like I thought
Age of Ultron was actually a pretty cool
storyline like I really enjoyed Age of
Ultron I had a great time reading it I
just don't like how the resolution the
resolution for Age of Ultron is like
well now the the time travel in Universe
has snapped back so the incursions are
happening because of you Wolverine and
Angela here because of you Wolverine and
that that's the effect of it and now
we've got like this really long running
New Avengers storyline like that is one
of the things I don't like about
Marvel's focus and like I mean see it
was interesting to me when it came to
Wolverine because Wolverine just showed
up he was anti-hero y y y did some stuff
and loved like he was in love with Jean
Gray and she was like I love you too but
get the [__] out of here because I'm
with Cyclops so like it was cool you
know in the early 90s and the late 90s
and all of a sudden it was just like
Wolverine everything like everything we
WS around wolver they did that with
Deadpool I mean Deadpool got into
everything yeah but at least Deadpool
provided comic relief like Wolverine
kind of like Deadpool was like Deadpool
is the open mic night of
Marvel everyone is almost everyone who
thinks they're hilarious is like let me
take Deadpool and be hilarious with him
well what what makes Deadpool work like
not work so much but crazy is he panders
and I I love Deadpool and I'll go ahead
and say but he panders to the
13-year-old kid yep he runs around
cutting off heads making jokes with
severed heads and going boob and that's
that's Deadpool Deadpool is a Comic-Con
attendee why do you think he's the most
cplay guy ever because it's really
[__]
easy um oh I just do Spider-Man with a
Cowboy head witho yeah I'm Hello Kitty
Deadpool yeah um so yeah you know but
but let's let's try to well another
thing I have to say about Wolverine is
is not only is Wolverine and everything
but it seems like he as a character
doesn't want to be involved with
anything that he's in yeah until he's
actually forced to be involved with it
yep so it's like it's like Marvel puts
him in there just to be the guy who's
like angsty and like no I don't want to
do that y we shouldn't do this in a mess
with things you're right but to keep us
on track here s and Dave what are your
favorite crossovers we still haven't
done that we just had like a 20-minute
discussion about Age of Apocalypse
yeah uh well from what I've been reading
recently I would say Annihilation is is
really good Rob was right when he said I
would enjoy that event and it was my
first was my first uh read of a
Interstellar or like Galactic Marvel
event and you really felt like all of
these cultures and everything were
getting wiped out by this Annihilation
wave that nobody could stop yeah yeah
and it was just by complete chance that
like a couple people managed to like
stand up to it and stop it yeah I mean
that's that's that's one of the reasons
why it was so cool is because like
almost all the crossover events up until
Annihilation with the exception of maybe
like a couple took place on earth like
they were just like Earth confined
events and then you have the
annihilation wave where annihilist is
like I need to destroy all life in the
universe because the Earth 61 Universe
616 universe is encroaching onto mine
and I'm going to rule this universe by
ruling nothing and so he just sends the
annihilation wave through and it just
like literally eats and kills everything
but but it huge like Intergalactic event
yeah it really set up Infinity too
because when you saw them like as a Last
Stand say like you know we couldn't stop
this Annihilation wave before but at
least the annihilation wave might be
able to stop this they Unleashed them
and then it just got demolished and you
were like man that was like that was
like a real Hail Mary
pass got yeah like completely screwed
that um that was a good like Infinity
was a good one the whole thing with uh
like the builders and all that kind of
stuff and everything with the builders
and the Avengers was awesome yeah
everything else was not like like what
we do with Thanos in the end I thought
Thanos was shoehorned in and crappy oh I
don't think so it was only because he
smirked at the end of Avengers you know
that they only put him in there because
he's smirked at the end of The Avengers
dude they didn't even take the time to
explain why Thanos is back Thanos has no
and then he's like oh my son's here oh
your son that's the flimsiest excuse
because we created him for this stupid
thing
no no make it something else if you want
to make it like he's angry make him
angry at Star-Lord for trapping him in
the cancerverse and then have him go
destroy Earth like make that your reason
but don't make it because don't create a
character for him to need like don't
create a McGuffin that you're never
goingon to use again that he he's gone
he's long gone like we'll see him I say
in five years he'll come back or
something only if
J yeah yeah stupid I know I don't and it
was socure too because they never even
hinted at it it's just like oh
conveniently Thanos discovered he has a
son on Earth and conveniently oh there's
no Avengers on Earth so Thanos is now
going to go look for his son I like the
idea of Thanos being like there's no
Avengers and Luke Cage is like who are
you calling not an Avenger and then he
gets his ass Tred and you're like yeah
but like yeah not you not you buddy but
like you know it but everything
everything with the builders and Thor
and Captain America leading the like
like seeing you know Captain Marvel with
the Guardians is cool but like seeing
Captain America help the shiar fight the
builders is awesome yeah and having the
rest of the universe go like maybe we
should take these people seriously
because we all knelt before like these
Builders like the accusers themselves
were were were demolished and only Thor
killed like that's awesome yeah have
killed a builder in an amazing way
though yeah I mean he threw like he
threw his hammer into the air or
something like that and then he called
it back to him and like it impaled
him
gravitational yeah no he left it behind
because he can always call a hammer he
left it behind and then he went and
bowed and basically like submitted to
the builders so he bowed before them so
that they would take him to like the
leader of the Builder Army yep so that
he could he could bow and say that I I
submit in the moment when he got in
front of him he's like Mo his ham like
his ham fly down builds up the the it
builds up momentum from the
gravitational pole of a of a moon and
just ex just builds up this Force it's
just waiting to be picked up and he's
like okay and it just brings all that
energy back yeah through his chest so
awesome okay I just thought though that
it was a little too like easy for them
in the end to hijack those
ships like they kind of just use that as
a way to end the event I just go the
problem is with infinity is that was it
was like eight books in The Infinity
story line then like eight crossover you
have to read them books so they had
already had like 30 books and they were
like how do we cram four story lines
into 30 books how about we just make one
story in one effing title how about that
but see that that made sense though
because I mean I mean Civil War was a
year long secret invasion was a year
long people were tired of these yearlong
events people were like I'm tired of
reading comics for a year like I want I
like I want like three stories like I
want three Comics it's almost like they
said we have to cover these three
stories over the next crossovers but we
want to get things more in line with
what people are going to start seeing in
the movies yep and these three don't
match up for that so let's shoehorn them
all into one big event and get them out
of the way so that the universe is set
up for this stuff yep that's exactly
what they did yeah I mean that that much
I understand but I don't know man I mean
I think that that people love major
crossover events like people love seeing
like the Avengers and what's left of the
X-Men and like all these different
groups get together and fight but the
problem is that people like seeing that
for a short amount of time and then I
want to see it drag on and on and on
that's why like you know that's why
certain events are great like they I
like when they do these like out of
continuity events like you know Punisher
Kills the Marvel Universe four issues
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe four
issues this is fun I love it this is
great four issues and I'm done you know
yeah
yeah and it's and it's cool the way they
do it you know I mean like I mean go
ahead Dave then people complain about
how they their character that they loved
didn't get killed in the right way
because they they got killed oh well
that guy got killed in like two frames
yeah well it's it's like like we had
talked about before like like how do you
kill wolverin the Xavier protocol say
just chop off his head and separate his
head and his body it's the only
foolproof way to keep him dead yep I
mean it doesn't need regrow everything I
think the only way you can actually kill
Wolverine is drown him CU it's the only
that if you uh if you take him out of
the water his lungs will heal itself
right well yeah but it's the only
that'll keep him down for a while I mean
you'd have to you'd have to drown him
and then like Wolverine has a single
cell cutting his head off is gonna do
[__] we might just get two Wolverines
with that
no I mean I mean this is this is this is
like the Xavier protocols and and the
Xavier protocols were establish as the
foolproof way to kill every xman they
are wrong and that that leaves me very
well of reonda they made very well
of they changed his healing Factor like
twice since he okay okay I I don't
follow Wolverine for a reason I don't
like Wolverine we need Styles crossover
Marvel crossover that he likes but why
is there not just like a dozen
Wolverines running around like what in
his genan says this finger is not
Wolverine do not regenerate this but
this cell is Wolverine regenerate all of
this I don't know I think it's his
head no cuz he's whatever head is
connected to he has been nothing but
bones and just regrown everything yep
yeah I mean that's what happened in
Civil War like when nitro blew up I mean
like he he blew up and totally
incinerated Wolverine down to his
skeleton and then over the span of like
four minutes he grew back like
completely grew back but like you would
you would cook his brain but his brain
would still be in there no once you
destroy a once you destroy a brain it's
done I think it was age of the
Apocalypse though but it was like there
is an instance where it was a single
cell yep and he grew out of it h yeah I
I don't know I don't I don't follow I
don't like wolver rain's character
because I feel like wolver rain is a cop
out for like everything Marvel does like
he's in way too many things there's no
reason wolver rine should be in like
13,000 Comics no he's you know he's just
in way too many things he's he's not
that good of a character he's really not
he's not that interesting that's that's
why I'm hoping when Marvel kills him off
like he stays dead like I want to see
him go the way I don't ever want to see
him come back it's not gonna happen it
needs to happen it's not gonna happen
he's they're not gonna kill Wolverine
wait before we go rant about Wolverine
for 30
minutes because we will ran to Wolverine
for 30 minutes
yeah um Marvel crossover oh Marvel
crossover uh Spider Island was pretty
awesome uh I love big time and uh Secret
Wars secret Wars man that's just you're
just gonna list them off we're done all
right Secret Wars man I just thought
really it was first on i' read and uh I
was was just like this is fun and
basically it feels like everybody every
every event has been trying to like have
that same feeling you get when you read
Secret Wars where you're like look
everyone's here at the same time and
they have to fight those bad guys that's
it wasn't wasn't and everyone's getting
a new toy Spider-Man's gonna be a black
costume
yay secet war is just a giant Gladiator
event it's not even that a gym shooter
an episode of Masters of the Universe
Wolverine 30 minute rant
approaching oh uh no secret Wars is just
an episode of He-Man where it's like
that's these guys fight these guys
everyone fights nobody dies everybody
dies everyone comes back the end that's
that's exactly it man like like Secret
Wars picks up like that I mean it's just
suddenly they're on H the ground running
people are like what the hell is going
on like well some super entity from
Beyond the Marvel Multiverse it's
encompassing of all all the stuff in his
universe is just just wants to see what
happens if good guys fight bad guys he
wants to see what's stronger good versus
evil he's like you're good and you're
evil and but he also doesn't even
understand that he
yeah keep up with them on the secret
Wars I mean that's that's the way it was
explained in in the Marvel and like when
you actually get into the beyonder and
you actually get into like like his run
in like new Avengers and like when you
get into like the X-Men explanation and
all that kind of stuff like um all all
they really say is like initially he was
like this Cosmic entity or he was like
the sentience of all com
into Multiverse he just looked our
universe and saw like well let's just
see what happens if we have good guys
fight bad guys and so he created
everything but the secret Wars was it
was gym shooter and jym shooter made
some of the best Comics between like 78
and ' 87 he made some of the best comic
stories to ever come out of Marvel like
I really love a lot of the stuff that he
made but um he was uh he was really cool
in terms of in terms of that story and
that's what made the story cool was
because because you got to see the fight
that a lot of people want like a lot of
people wanted to see what would happen
if you had like some of the biggest
super villains versus some of the
biggest superheroes in Marvel fighting
when there's like really no
ramifications for their actions and
that's why super Wars is cool because it
was a planet that was created with
nothing on it and so they just went and
just fought and destroyed stuff except
for a black suit except for well yeah
except for the symbiot and the Hulk
holding up like half the plan that's one
of the coolest Hulk moments people think
like people find that to be one of the
best like Hulk moments ever is Hulk up a
mountain saving everybody that's
freaking awesome yeah it's it's really
cool the way they do it it's it's like
like they have the incredible hul
they're like 2,000 feet below the
surface like the Incredible Hulk is
holding him out or something like that
like he's very angry and he's just like
sitting there with his arms out holding
him out enough yep and he's losing
Banner as the story is going on it's fun
cool all right next question then keep
we'll keep this moving keep this rolling
all right this has turned into a Q&A
with the weekly poll so I think it's
actually yeah it's pretty cool actually
all right every they want to know our
opinions about our are we tired of
seeing Batman everywhere just like
Wolverine Deadpool no I like I only like
Batman I love Batman's character you
know what I I don't I don't mind it and
I'm probably the biggest DC guy here
because I only read Scott sniders Batman
and him in Justice League I avoid
everything else think matter of fact I
have like five books of Eternal over
here that I'm just ignoring because they
crap I think they could cut down on the
number of characters that originated
from Batman like how many the bat family
you know they've got they've got Batman
they've got Batwoman got Batgirl they've
got uh he has to call in the bat Army
eventually he becomes the bat army with
Batman Incorporated Grant's little
creation I think like really quick my
just really initial thoughts on Batman I
think it'd be way cooler if there was
one bat title and it came out like
Spider-Man uh
the what they did when SP uh brand new
day where it was three Amazing
Spider-Mans a month I think they should
do three Batman titles a month it's one
title it's like just Batman I think they
have it I agree with you on that because
what I do dislike about Batman is we
have Batman Scott Snider we have Batman
and Robin we have Batman Detective
Comics we have Batman and the Justice
League and they have and none of them
have anything to do with each other they
don't it's all separate story lines and
which is fine to an extent but where's
my continuity where did all of this take
place well and like some of them are not
go like you could with a with zero years
with the the the the twoyear long
freaking Scott Snider Batman story he
just did that he just I'm waiting for
the trade on by the way cuz I I was not
it just ended you're going to get it
soon it just know I know I've got the
last issue over there I'm like board and
bag I'm getting the trade yeah screw
this so it ended that was a like a year
that they could have
had like a core Batman book Running
concurrently that was in the current
continuity I say the current current the
core Batman stuff was not even in
continuity right now yeah the only
continuity Batman was Justice League I
know now that should I should say I hate
brand new day but I love the idea of
three Spider-Man titles a month so
that's what I was thinking I don't want
to like make Batman young and hip and
whatever I just wanted to see like
Batman three times a month in one title
in one shared continuity doesn't have to
be like one story like when they like
they did in the 90s where it was like
Batman detective Legends and Shadow and
they all were night like and they all
told one story written by kind of one
person Eternal yeah like bat Turtle bat
Turtle comes out what once every other
week no it's it's a weekly book holy
[__] like that's awesome that's why I'm
so far behind yeah but it's like that's
awesome I should want well every other
week is good with this like it's like
they like Scott SN they're not look at
the names on this fourth oh my God I'm a
firm believer that Scott Snider writes
every other book because every other
book has to do with his storyline yeah
and then the opposing book is like some
well on the way to this location Batman
ran into Red Robin and theyve gone on
this crazy extra Adventure yeah and look
if that's the how you sell Comics that's
how you sell Comics but whatever I mean
I mean Marvel Marvel did the same thing
back with Nick Fury I mean Nick Fury for
like when Nick Fury popped up he was of
course like the World War II and then
when they gave us like uh Nick Fury as
part of the whole CIA Shield thing like
he had his eye patch and all Marvel did
is they adapted Nick Fury Comics to the
point where they gave him an eye patch
to like fit in so that you basically had
like this followup like they ran at the
same time but you saw where like 1945
Nick Fury was growing into you know 1960
spy Nick Fury which I thought was pretty
cool which doesn't even matter now
because they're all life model
Deco are there any extra
questions
on I was just gonna ask you guys what
you thought of Max like the max Universe
I hate oh oh oh Marvel Max Marvel Max is
awesome man that adult oriented
stuff they did the first one was good
then they're just like oh we Mak an
adult
line yeah the next question though the
next there's still plenty in here and
I'm trying to pick them out as we're
going okay uh we'll go back to we can go
back to M whole Max discussion because I
hated that's why I asked uh where is it
oh what do you guys think of the new
arot TV show now that it's uh I know
we've briefly discussed it before um oh
it's because I'm wearing an arrow tshirt
oh
yeah um I hated season one loved season
two and I'm excited about season three
that's pretty much where I see with
there first four episodes are boring I
don't care I sto watching yeah I haven't
watched it at all I've only seen the
first
season so I'm I'm planning on seeing the
second season Once it comes out on
Blu-ray Benny's the odd man out y weird
I agree I mean St stopped watching the
first four episodes Dave watched the
first season and the first season is
horrendous I watched it over the span of
like a year and a half like I didn't
even like I just it was one of those
things it came on Netflix and be like
I'm bored let's watch an episode of
Arrow that was horrible whatever and I
eventually got to season two and it
really picked up and got good yeah
that's what I hear I just I don't I
don't I don't want to dedicate my time
to like skipping seasons and [__] I'm
not gonna lost it up with arrow oh God
that's but but it's the same situation
as Marvel AG of Shield the first 11 12
episodes garbage I like those show I
like that show I like all the shows I
don't like the first half of the season
the second half I was glued to my seat
like what's gonna happen next week yeah
but I was glued because I did the I made
I get I I spent the time I I made I
watched them all too and I was attached
to characters I like don't like the
first half of the first season I just
don't it's too much of this oh let's get
to know everybody it's too much Jos
Weeden in my superhero show funny thing
is I don't think Weeden worked on that
[__] like I think we Weeden was the like
he was like script punch up with silly
ass L like let me Weeden up these three
lines in the episode and send off I
don't write the episodes I don't read
the the episodes I just like so give me
the give me read it to me okay that make
that make him say something kind of
firefly e
send the the day and age that we are now
I don't think there's much room for a
whole new Jos Weeden 20 episodes a
season of character development to get
to that amazing final finale The Buffy
Angel formula I don't think would work
nowadays and it looks like that's what
they were trying with Asians of Shield
let's just build up this characters so
you're attached so when that big screw
you happens you're attached to it
but I have too much to watch now there's
too much good shows to watch now and I
don't have time to really give 12
episodes of just watching us learn who
sky is watching us learn yeah watching
Coulson deal with the fact that he's
come back and never actually learning
anything I'm really hoping uh like you
like you said with arrow that it's it's
picking up with season two well they've
already said the they in girlfriend and
stuff like that're they're bringing in
Heroes now yeah I'm really hoping they
they bring in more like superpowered
Heroes yeah and more of what's going on
with with the the stuff that's happening
off of Earth honestly we had more
superpowered guys happening in Buffy and
Angel every other week Buffy and Angel's
like hey look a new vampire that's super
strong and Buffy's gonna get some new
super weapon and here we go Buffy the
Vampire let me tell you something about
Buffy the Vampire Slayer that
show was one of the dumbest shows that
i' ever seen in my life that show no
under no circumstance
not anything by what Universe would
anyone believe that Buffy the Vampire
Slayer was a genuinely good story The it
was based it was based and then Angel
wraps into it so beautifully it was
based off a
Terri it was we so polarized with Rob on
everything that's why this is a great
show Rob against us and us against Rob
all the time well because because
honestly Dave what here's what would
happened if if Rob was like I like Buffy
then I'd be like I like Buffy so I like
yeah Buffy was great and then you'll be
like yeah Buffy was awesome and then
we'll be like next topic I watch I
watched the pilot of pu of Buffy hated
it and didn't watch anymore uh people
who tried to convert me into it were
like watch this episode I'm like this is
dog [__] so I was like no I don't care
watch I watch the first season over it's
like three episodes I just don't want to
and and it was okay but I mean it it
might just be because I have no
Nostalgia for it at this point like like
it might have been like really good but
now it's like they shot it with such
shitty cameras because it was a pretty
lowbudget show to start out with first
place that I'm like oh God all the Grain
and like everything's out of
focus on a side note before I go to the
next question has anybody tried to watch
those like sitcoms that we all used to
watch in the
90s and step by step and go back to
Family Matters and you watch all the
stuff that as kids we loved but now
you're like that is so so bad so bad you
know what holds up oh dude like Salute
Your Shorts and Nick shows it's funny
Nickolodeon
sitcoms hold up better I think Salute
Your Shorts hey dude uh they were never
do Are You Afraid of the
Dark they all still hold up they never
stayed with like the current DNA they
didn't follow pop culture and everything
they that's why they stand up you know
things like and stuff like oh well
currently there's a big issue happening
in the real world so we're going to see
how it reflects on our characters and
now you're like I don't give a crap
about the president stepping down
because Bill Clinton got a [__] you
know I mean I'm not ashamed to admit it
like I had a crush on Clarissa Explains
It All and oh Alex Mack Clarissa oan oh
I I had that Crush strong man I was
like I wasn't I wasn't old enough I'm
not as old as you guys are I had dude I
was crushing so hard on is always I will
always have a special place my heart for
Clarissa here because this is so going
through the comments about what we said
about the whole just Weeden thing y um a
bit late for school keeping away oh I
just want to watch the new Flash uh sky
is a scroll uh Troy is saying sky is a
scroll I
hope refuses to make a female spin-off
because they're making Agent Carter how
does that work Jos weed and sty needs to
be put through a filter to get to the
core of what makes him good yes Buffalo
was only good for one season then it got
very very CW um that I agree with I
agree with that 100 watching agans of
Shield at the first three episodes
because they were just annoying teenage
science kids God they're annoying I did
too I got out of AG Buffy uh Andrew
Garfield or Toby McGuire uh Andrew
Garfield I think he looks more like the
role yep Garfield's better Garfield is a
better actor yeah um what do you think
Dave give what's yours oh uh I I was
just going to say like I I stopped
watching Agents of Shield after after
the first couple episodes to when I got
out of until the end of the season
because it was just it was boring oh my
God you're out of your
mind true no way Dave Dave I'm
disappointed in you yeah I really am
disappointed toar moving to these list
here what's where is it Kevin Conroy
Spider-Man indeed Sonic says Josh
Keening is the K is the Kevin conro of
Spider-Man voices agreed okay uh Sonic
the Hedgehog loves Angry Beavers
remember that one anded and Ed like
those show yeah I mean I was more of
like a Rocko Modern Life Rugrats kind of
kid but I was too old those shows life
yeah man Rugrats was awesome your shorts
does not hold up although I'd pay to see
Sponge and Donkey lip
spin-off SL your shorts um okay here we
go what's your guys opinion about Batman
Arkham Knight coming out it's garbage oh
I know the the the game you cannot give
a doesn't shoot we can't give sorry I
thought you meant the I thought you
meant the DVD movie adaptation of the
game oh that's coming out yeah I not the
video game video game looks awesome I'm
totally in oh no no dud dude so I saw a
great little like joke thing about it
and they're like you know Batman's like
look Alfred look look at my new uh my
new uh riot control suppressing gun and
he's like Bruce that's that's a Gatling
gun you're going to kill people he's
like no it's Riot suppressing I will
suppress the riots with these bullets
you that that you you don't you remember
your parents died you can't do that and
he's like no no I'm not going to kill
anyone it's R
suppressing he's like rred check out my
new Riot suppressing missile launcher
and like missiles pop up and he's like
missile launchers in the name you're
going to kill people and he's like no
it's to get rid of tanks and he's like
does it have rubber bullets there's
people in the tanks Bruce yeah I no that
game will right suppressing nuclear law
he's like I give up and he walks
away does it have robber bullets at
least oh I don't know but uh the game
play looks awesome I don't like them
[__] on the Batman L like that you
can't just give him Gatling guns oh my
God here we go Benny's going to start
crying those great big alligator tears
they pooped on the Batman
L well I agree because that's an
integral part of his character yeah is
not to use guns so like I don't know
like
it does kill people not buets is he GNA
find rubber bullets and cachets around
the city is he going to villains who
have guns and conveniently pick up
rubber bullets his ammo like it just
doesn't work I mean Batman Batman used
guns when he he used a gun when he first
showed up yeah when he first appeared in
coms got dark side but I don't see Dark
Side walking around an Arkham
Knight Batman doesn't use guns that's a
thing that like even though he was he
had used guns before Batman doesn't use
guns it's just a thing like I'm like
it's just something that's like it's a
it's a it's ingrained in the character
it is but at the same time in in Dark
Knight Returns they Frank Miller wrote
in a tank he was using a tank yeah with
rubber
bullets rubber bullets that were causing
explosions explosions yes whatever he's
shooting here's apparently the plot he's
shooting at AI controlled
tanks everything you guys are saying in
there everything everything you guys are
saying about the excuses is all excuses
to give Batman a tank with guns yep yep
that sense viably I don't even want
those aren't being driven by humans
that's an excuse give me another Arkham
City game I don't need a freaking tank
on my Batman game agreed yeah hardly
agree I only played be amazing the story
will probably be amazing if you put the
tank just messes with everything so much
yep I mean I only played Batman uh
Arkham Asylum um and then Arkham City go
play the and then Arkham City and I
haven't played any of the other ones
yeah Arkham City well Arkham Origins is
the only one you're missing and it's
fairly recent Arkham Origins Su that one
just came out it's bad when you compare
it to the other games if it came out
first it would have been great oh yeah
obviously but it's just that but the
studio that made Arkham Arkham Origins
would never have made that game first
because it is a clone of those like it
is just a sequel that is just ripping
off the other two games like it with
with no heart it's just boring and like
you know what happens and all the voice
acting is like uh no it's the only game
I stopped playing after a couple hours I
like the idea of the Joker like when you
play as the Joker as the Red Hood and
stuff that was cool but making Harley
Quinn fall for the Joker during the
sequence was kind of like a neat idea
that was really flimsy if you think
about it for too long um otherwise the
voice acting was me and the story was eh
um okay Scarlet Witch gives me a bunch
of xes but here's a good follow-up
question from Sonic the Hedgehog one he
it Scarlet say I'm so full of energy and
then she just said
exis um what would you guys want in an
Arkham equivalent of Spider-Man like a
real yeah I want that I want Arkham City
I want Arkham or no uh je s stupid
Arkham everything I would I would take I
would take Arkham City but it would be
New York obviously Peter Parker
Spider-Man as the head guy and as cliche
as it sounds I'd want Sinister 6 but I
would want the original comic book
Sinister 6 what I also would want is
cameos here and there like characters
popping in from time to time so have you
guys not played The Amazing Spider-Man
video game no I've
seen seen that game played tried to to
do you know what okay you know that we
have a movie coming out let's make
something similar yeah that that I I
watched that game played online and that
game looked so much like garbage I I uh
I I legally acquired a copy of the game
and it and within 10 minutes the game
was garbage and I was [__] on it I
still play it looks it looks awful it's
like the old N64 Superman game like just
a big like the I don't know about you
guys but like the riot cops were like
ridiculously glitchy for me the whole
game was garbage it was garbage yeah no
it was no I I want to see like a
welldeveloped
give me like three years to develop even
like give it to bethesa let them spend
like like five or six years developing
that [__] but I want to see like a
Spider-Man game that has great character
development that has a great story to it
that has villains that are more than
just punch them three times and then 100
points pops up and you win like I want
to see really really really good
storytelling if I had it my way I would
even do an Arkham Origins equivalent of
Spider-Man I would do like a Fallout 3
or Skyrim like Spider-Man game that's
what I would do man like
open is now working on a Spiderman game
here's the thing because they've passed
off the license for Batman I don't know
no they haven't Rock doing Arkham night
now yeah Arkham City no uh yeah they
passed off they they didn't pass it off
the GU they're doing the like whole act
division like no no no what's going on
is this rock steady doesn't actually own
Batman it's the the parent company does
and they hired Rock Steady to make the
games but since Rocksteady was going to
make Arkham Knight for Next Generation
that left two to three years of no
Batman games so the owners then hired
the guys to make Batman Arkham Origins
yeah that's why Rock Steady has nothing
to do with it yeah that's also why it's
kind of lame yeah yeah um I would love
to see Arkham Asylum like literally
Batman Arkham Asylum where Batman goes
to Arkham Asylum it's an island off the
coast of Gotham City they're all these
villains in the in the Asylum and the
inmates are running it it's Spider-Man
it's the rat
Galactus has attacked New York and all
the superheroes are fighting Galactus
and when you go outside you see all this
or not Galactus but like something is
happening over there there's a big
superhero fight yeah and everyone's busy
but you can see the fight kind of
happening every time you go outside so
you know you have to stop the riot
that's happening at this prison or it
will add to the Carnage that's going on
outside so kind of like the the goblin
Nation thing where are you you see every
other superhero here for the first time
ever they're just pre but it also
explains why no one shows up to help you
and why you're fighting everybody Goblin
Nation man or why only a couple people
show up to help you or check on you
right maybe C shows up to give you
supplies maybe Iron Man drops a box of
like are we developing a game now that's
literally the game but like the game
literally is Arkham Asylum but it's
Spider-Man and you call it the raft and
it's that that's the whole and you fight
and you can fight purp man and like
Craven and La every you you could even
do like the Arkham City plot the raft is
getting expanded so we sectioned off
this part of New York that's the secret
why don't you start that big no you
start small oh oh I'm sorry I right you
need to milk this franchise for all it's
worth you start with a great game you
write you have Dan slot WR it and you
just say go for it it's literally just
the same [__] freaking game with Batman
only it's Spider-Man and there and you
explain the reason why superheroes
aren't there is because they're all
fighting galatis over there and
Spider-Man's like I have to take it upon
myself to fight all these guys but I
have to shows up and everyone's busy and
like he just steps on the raft breaking
open the wall or something and so that'd
be
great some kind of explosion or
something like that but that sounds like
the new like the new Avengers story line
the break no that is like that's it that
that is the new Avengers and like so
it's kind so you could you also get
comic book fans involved because they're
like oh that's new Avengers and you're
like
yeah only The Avengers aren't there it's
just
Spider-Man Spiderman so
the next question because I think I
think s has now planned our entire game
out just hire us to do it guys we've got
this literally I was playing Arham
Arkham Asylum for the first time when it
came out and I went they could L just do
Spider-Man on the raft and that would be
fine
right next question is um actually from
he asked it a couple times Troy and Judy
um he wanted to know what we thought
about the Deadpool trailer um that we
actually discussed on last week's weekly
poll but I think overall we all agreed
we liked it we'd love to see it we just
don't know if it's going to happen yep
so it it looked cool it looked really
great i' be in that's it right okay um
and they want to know what our favorite
Spidey costume is oh black and white
definitely yeah you like the black
costume yeah is that because you're just
swinging Luke Cage kind of guy no I mean
just the just I mean just I'm talking
about like old school like you know
symbiot pre Venom Spider-Man costume is
what I like trying to think of which one
I ran around it I want to say it was
iron spider I lik iron spider when I
when I was playing him spider was really
cool cuz he gets the arms that I've
never understood why he just doesn't use
anymore yeah let's get arms of that crap
you know why because Iron Man because
Iron Man betrayed him and like put all
these sensors in his caste to study his
powers and stuff yeah but Spider-Man
want to trust Iron Man to create him
another c yeah I mean but Spider-Man has
used it again because he has rewired it
and then superior Spider-Man used A
variation of it and it just seems like
this is highly usful and apparently in
your
closet I mean there's something to be
said about the old the old Spider-Man
like the original Spider-Man costume red
white and blue but I think that the
Venom Spider-Man costume I think it's
probably one of the cooler costumes that
he that he had I mean even at the end of
Civil War like he came back with that
costume so I thought I'm just gonna read
this one comment from this commenter
dumb [__] says hell yeah all right
move on oh
yeah I um
with the Spider-Man costumes it's hard
like when I in the in the N the 80s and
90s I loved the black costume yeah I
loved seeing it in art like I love the
old web of Spider-Man number one IM like
image um but it got old and the the the
the costume has kind of changed over the
years like they really changed the
design and it's like I don't really like
what people think it looks like now I
don't know it it's funny like they
people go with more like the Ron version
of it where it's like this weird spider
and I'm not a fan um but as far as
Spider-Man costumes go I think my
favorite classic It Goes Classic
2099 oh that is a good one and then and
there a toss between black and iron
spider I hated the iron spider costume
when it first came out I was like this
is cheap and stupid
but the only thing I don't like about
iron spider I love the functionality I
love the fact that it's apparently in
his closet and he can pull it out when
he actually needs it right I love
everything about it I don't like the
original color design because they've
kind of toned it down a little the
original color design was totally Tony
Stark going look at the armor it's
yellow red and yellow y it's red and
gold Tony Stark's color scheme drives me
crazy yeah the the red and yellow like
ketchup and mustard I mean I I do give
my friend a hard time because he really
hates that color scheme like he like is
OCD about not
having ketchup and mustard
but like I really I really think it's a
design I just want to say one thing now
because I'm looking at all our time
stamps and everything else and we're
hitting our end so while you're
discussing this and this gives them the
lag time okay about your your orange
mustard and your friend of the OCD I was
listening last question everyone ask
your last question for the for us yes
and I will pick out the best one and
when we're done discussing the iron
spider situation I'll find it and I'll
I'll read it off yeah yeah because we're
at hour 40 even with the opening thing
and all the flubs and all that crap so I
don't know where the image of the I
don't know where we are with the actual
recording so I'm playing as sick the
image of the the thing that convinced me
it was an awesome looking costume was
the iron Spider-Man Civil War image
where he's here I'll put it in the chat
oh I
can't so so we started in an hour or or
we're at an hour and 15 right now or an
hour and 10 minutes right now oh are we
a regular podcast we started the podcast
at around 40 minutes yeah on the counter
yep oh so we got a little while yeah I
mean we're still chatting and for all we
know this last question is gonna stretch
out forever so true yeah but it's
Spider-Man over the Captain America
shield that I was like this is awesome
so hold on hold on run that by me again
now H what are you talking about now oh
the the reason like I always thought
that the Spider-Man Iron Man costume was
kind of lame but then I saw that one
promo image from Civil War which I
posted to you guys I can't post in the
chat but I can okay there you go wait no
I don't think I can I think I think Rob
has to actually oh uh but uh it's is it
in the chat on Skype yeah yeah I can't
do it you have to do
Rob all right I'm also looking at the
time stamp over here my on my local time
and I gotta get running soon so my Rob
at 40 minutes of technical difficulties
all right let's post this in the
chat but anyway so I love that image and
I was like okay I can't post it in there
really well it's fine it's just it's the
image of Spider-Man like kind of like
like this and he's got the Captain
America shield Webb to the ground it was
cool I was like this is cool oh yeah
that's um yeah that's right after their
fight uh yeah that was that was pretty
interesting yeah I like that so many
good questions coming through
here so yeah let's see let's hear it
okay okay I'll start at the top for the
some of these really good ones all right
yeah so first off who has the best beard
Sal or Dave Oh
Me Oh well me me I mean
I love how you both double took on that
wait what that's the best question best
beard all right I'll take it mine's I
guarantee you I've had mine longer okay
yeah well maybe
2003 yeah you've had yours longer mine's
not really a beard it's just stubble
it's just I got too lazy to shave it off
mine mine can grow in full really fast
though that's cool like I can like grow
a mountain man beard in like three weeks
nice I cannot I can grow a beard but I
can't grow a mountain man beard okay all
right all right so M man beard okay so
we're discussing who can grow it better
now that's right next question what is
your guys opinion on Sony trying to make
a Venom and Carnage movie go shotgun
style go oh I'm very disappointed this
gonna be a total flop they're going to
tone down Carnage which shouldn't be
done if you're going to put Carnage in a
film it's got to be right at R Cletus
Cassidy is totally insane he kills
people arbitrarily for no reason at all
and does it in really gruesome ways when
he first showed up during Maximum
Carnage he was killing people and riding
his initials on the wall in blood so you
can't tone his character down Venom
would not be remotely interesting if
they decide to go the same route that
Sam Ry did when they made Venom in their
whole thing they'd have to reboot Venom
give his give him his own movie so
people understand what the hell is going
on with this character because he's more
than a guy that attacks Spider-Man Y and
then you have to follow up with the
Carnage movie so yeah now what I think
is the consensus with us is Sony just
needs to give the rights to Marvel agre
that's the answer pretty much if anybody
asks what what are your opinions about
Sony doing
XYZ my answer is it sucks until you you
tell me what do you think about Sony
giving the rights to Marvel back yeah
like giving the rights to Spider-Man
back then it's I think that's a great
idea
yeah shotgun question number next
shotgun question I'm cutting so we can
keep it moving keep moving right is
Scott Lang a better choice for Ant-Man
than I guess Ant-Man yes he's a more
entertaining character and actually I
think he was referenced in uh Captain
America the Winter Soldier I was
watching that last night and uh there
was that scene where what's his name was
talking about people they were keeping
an eye on and he mentioned he said
Steven strange and then he said a valid
Victorian in high school oh so I think
they were talking about Scot yeah but
okay what is your opinion about the WASP
not being Henry prim's
daughter hold on what now supposed to be
his wife yeah
yeah think
I think tevia is a little missed up so
how do you feel about her not being his
wife yeah is understand that she's
supposed to be his daughter I think yeah
I think they oh okay so they're gonna
make her the daughter instead of the
wife now yeah because they're gonna make
Henry pimp really old right yeah yeah I
think that what they're gonna do I think
that I think that Jan van dy's gonna be
the mom like I think that they are gonna
keep her
as Hank Pimp's wife but they're going to
have a new wasp with a new like it's
going to be their
daughter I think that's the plan there
you go yeah question later he said our
our opinion on her not being Janet vany
yeah I mean like that's too bad Janet
vany was a founding member of The
Avengers she deserves her shot in The
Avengers she deserves to be on the team
it should be her it's not that's too bad
as long as we get a female wasp
character and they put her on the
freaking Avengers because we have one
woman and you've created three new
Avenger characters and so we have two
women and one of them is the Scarlet
Witch yeah lame no not lame Scarlet
Witch is yeah lame horrible the Scarlet
Witch is horrible by the way the Scarlet
Witch commented that she could grow a
beard but it would look really weird
with the
costume I want to see I want to see that
done Scarlet Scarlet Witch is a strong
female no she's she's an insane female
character is what she is I don't yeah I
don't care about her story or her
struggle and she's too complicated to
keep in the OR to use right now in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because you
don't have that added awesome of Magneto
maybe being in the movie yeah that's
that's true so I mean you know if you're
you're put a have to do with Magneto
she's his daughter man his daughter
really I've got a video I've got a video
with like 90,000 views explaining the SC
video watch my show hold on hold on hold
on no no wait wait wait hold on hold on
Dave Dave is your channel Rob Dave is
from your channel me and S have our own
channels Dave watches your videos and
that's how he got on this podcast I'm
disappointed Dave I totally had a brain
fart I was thinking Black Widow it's all
ironic Dave like you started out as a
part of my channel on this podcast and
You're Gonna Leave This podcast as part
of my channel so you know leave this
podcast me and S have excuses we work on
our own channels all day Dave you don't
even make videos you're still a Rob
viewer
so yeah I've actually thought about
doing a video on on Black Widow but no
byy B's 100% right here you yeah you're
a viewer well no no no no but I mean
you've got you've got black widow who is
a great character but it's like one
chick yeah and no powers no powers I'm
off of blaming the drugs for my mistakes
last week so I have to blame the
withdrawal for the drugs this week it's
all good man it's all good that's
equivalent of me saying I don't know
what's on comic story in that's just I
don't know what's on don't watch comic
story you know hey s what's going on
with the Lantern core colors and s's
like it's on your Channel Benny yeah
yeah what do you mean I just I just saw
you post
[Laughter]
that oh oh now everyone's screaming how
do you not know Magneto's
daughter you can do is ignore that
they'll be like oh Dave oh
Dave okay uh rob you should do you
should work for Marvel and upload all of
your explained videos to the Marvel
Network and watch all Marvel Tunes
movies and new and news from Marvel also
Comic-Con for 9.99 a month just like
they want you to make you a
Netflix I I am I am I'm never going to
charge money to see my stuff that's
crazy man yeah like I I don't even know
if I've ever seen somebody use the
YouTube like subscription fee like what
kind of an [__] would do that like
get on and be like if you want to watch
my videos you need to pay me like what
an there was like one I was
like and then I was like wait nobody's
going to even subscribe then no pay
money no way you know know that there's
a subscription service on YouTube that
no one uses right yeah you can put your
stuff behind a pay wall so that people
have to pay you that's what I'm talking
about actually have people pay a certain
monthly fee to watch exclusive content
we we should all start a weekly PLL
Patron I got that I'll explain that
later so chargeing people like that
wouldn't that be some [__] like like all
my subscribers are showing up to my
videos like upload Howard the Duck today
and it's like $5 to see this
video5 from me and S because we were
just curious oh my God that's crazy I
mean I have been thinking about starting
one by the way I'm not a patron yeah oh
for the record the the comment of Patron
um and I'm actually think about starting
one myself uh because I've seen a lot of
people doing it recently for YouTube but
the idea is that people can pay so that
you you know it can help supplement your
our income so we can make more videos
that's the thing it's just that's the
whole idea with Paton man I'm never
going to charge money for the videos I
make what it is is it's not you're
charging for the videos it's a donate
and you guys can help me do this it's
that kind of a thing alive in our case
it would be you'd be paying for
exclusive content like you would be you
get the videos for free but You' also
get like access to like a like to like
private conversations
or updates or behind the scenes footage
like you just get other stuff man I I I
work and then I come home and I make
video I mean there there's no behind the
scenes there's just
know would be just a video of
Rob that's that's what behind underwear
in the corner on his computer behind the
scenes Rob W making breakfast and
leaving the house yeah yeah that'd be
behind the scenes like it would just be
a webcam broadcast 24 hours a day
exclusive behind the scenes footage of
RA yeah if you want to watch your sleep
I guess it's
cool rob you don't buy com I mean just
like like sleep and fart in the bed I
mean that's what you want to see me do
then
yes I can do that but it's nothing this
with Troy wer Howard the Duck video uh
that'll be up today they're asking what
Patron is it's not it's not a pay to
watch the content it's a support your
creators they'll give you extra stuff
that's all it is never do that or Patron
Patron I thought it was Patron but siing
Patron exactly I've always called it
that because I want
Patron um last question um how do you
think of the transition of Falcon as the
new Captain America and then I'm want to
follow that up with the next line Dave
is so sexy right now Dave I was thinking
that Dave looks fabulous yeah first
question or second question first yes he
does as for I think anything's possible
I think if if Evans says no if Evans
actually makes good on his desire to
leave movies for a number of
years they could either re they could
either hire another blonde actor to play
him or they could transition to Falcon
and Stave it off for a little while
longer um sure I'd be F I'd be fine with
that I mean like I haven't seen it
actually an execution yet so you know I
think they' be I think they'd sooner do
the Bucky transition than the Falcon
transition I mean it's it's predictable
I mean I assume they're talking about
the comic
book yeah well it's happening in the
comics
first thinking that it's
because wants to leave that they're
gonna try to
to convince people that it's supposed to
happen like it happened in the comics
yeah no I mean it's it's predictable I
mean everybody knew that Falcon was
going to take over the role of Captain
America at some point in time Bucky
Barnes can't do it forever because he's
got a shady pass but you've got like
you've got you know Sam Wilson who's
like this upstanding guy you know he's
like Captain America except he didn't
have superier yeah I mean saying goodbye
to scarl wit
oh but um but yeah I mean you
know I knew it was coming I mean most
anybody who was paying attention knew
that at some point along the line Falcon
was going to take over the role of
Captain America he's been a sidekick
with him forever y i it just makes
perfect sense that if Captain America
ever stepped down that Falcon be the one
to take over the role and then with the
movie coming out now after seeing
Captain America the winner soldier like
Falcon really gonna take over the role
and yeah I'd be down with that so yeah
he's cool I wanted to see him on the
Avengers I was really sad that he's the
only one who's not going to be in The
Avengers yeah that's disappointing to me
like yeah he was is not going to be in
the new Avengers movie Falcon will not
be but war machine will be but not as
War Machine he's just going to be the
the token black guy for the movie that's
it there is a scene I mean like we could
I could I I read a scene from new from
Avengers 2 if you want to talk about it
like we could ruin that if you no no no
let's let's keep it spoiled the fre now
um L I want to ask one thing since
everyone's kind of half questioning
about the patrin thing okay and I want I
wanted to get your guys' opinion what I
was thinking about doing was using it so
that people who did donate towards the
channel they got to pick the next the
direction of the content I like that
that's pretty much that though can you
have like a donation system instead of
I'll show you the link to it after this
but it's pretty much just a donation
system people donate and they get like
special perks in your channel so they
can say like Rob they could say no you
will do Howard the Duck I don't care if
you're getting bored by it yeah um well
no I mean Howard the duck's already
finished I just need to upload that
today but um no I'm I mean I'm not going
to ask for donations I mean my Channel's
cranking along fine as it is so yeah
yeah I'm just I'm just saying that
because people are asking what it was
it's a donation B service that's all it
is yeah I just made a joke and I was
turned into what is that it's like an
ongoing kickstar yeah it is yeah so
anyway um rob you want to close us out
here uh yeah um all right so Howard the
Duck is going to be uploaded sometime in
the next couple hours or so uh alongside
this podcast which those of you that
haven't seen it we'll be able to see it
then including all the flubs and all the
screw-ups um you put all of that in
there well I mean I can't I can't edit
it out like it's live streaming and
YouTube automatically saves it so you
you can trim that you can edit it later
yeah you can use the you can you can
pick a new start Point that's why I
giving you
intros
huh good stuff there was there was a
reason why I did that Rob oh okay well
then I'll have to go through and and
make sure I do that um all right uh
after Howard the Duck I'm like I'm
debating on what I want to do I'm
thinking that maybe I'll do like some
Chris Claremont stuff but I also want to
like like get current with Marvel
stories because like everything that
I've been doing on my channel has been
like 1960s 70s and 80s and like I want
to get like '90s 2000s and current in
like Marvel events and stuff like that
so that's why I asked you about um Age
of Ultron Bing because I thought about
doing like a more in-depth version of
Age of Ultron and just telling people go
check out Benny's if you want a like a
really fast explanation like if you want
the finer point or the the like major
points on it I think hly between our two
channels because originally guys what
you guys don't know is Rob and I decided
that we wouldn't cross each other Turf
like as they came out like I wouldn't do
Age of Ultron then Roba do it a week
later right but it seems like the
audience in general likes my the calling
mind the cliffnotes version with the
dramatic reading and robs is actually
explaining so
yeah people people were saying to me
when I first started making videos like
do a full history of Marvel from the
year 2000 until now and I'm like why
would I do that like Marvel right like
an idiot in 200 won yeah I mean God
decision but but yeah so I'm I was
thinking about doing that or I'm I'm not
really sure I mean like like Troy and
Troy and Judy toink that's a heck of a
name wanted me to do uh original sin so
I might I might jump into original sin
I'm I'm not really sure but I want to
I'm waiting for it to end myself but but
I'm not doing any Titans or stuff I'm
doing the core plot and the whole Nick
Fury thousand one different things so oh
my God Nick Fury is so great in original
but I I do all current stories anyway so
yeah I might just make a video and just
ask people what they want to see so the
reason I asked about Max earlier is
there is a Nick Fury mask maxed out yes
now I think that's the only good one
which looks really good I think Andis WR
it didn't he yeah that's cool does most
of the yeah yeah of course s what's
going on over at TV L you have anything
today we launched a new episode of back
issues where we talk about flash point
and you upset me because you tore it
aart and I loved it we did I mean like
you know what I was I really tried you
can see me trying to be like no and then
it's cool and Ben like no it's not
that's not cool and I'm like for the
record I will say this about your show
that you just launched today yes the
funniest thing I found about it was
Ethan not letting go of the costume
thing how does it fit in the ring sound
how does it fit in the ring and I'm like
no I'm not GNA tell you that I have no
idea I'm like y this is great but uh
yeah we also do if you ever wanted to
see us act uh we play Batman so that's
cool and then the ending was the best
and then will have a tangents episode
that comes out that's like two minutes
that's like a lost conversation from
that episode of flasho so you can check
it all out of TV Little House on YouTube
good and over mine I'm launching the the
Green Lantern entities that everyone's
been asking for for the last like month
I started I started Guardians to the
Galaxy month and everyone's like what
about Green Lantern
entities I saw that I was looking
through that I'm just gonna say it real
quick Green Lantern entities there
really isn't much to say this one's a
snake this one's a bull that's pretty
much it so I got that I got that going
up today I'm I'm probably going to do
the know your Universe about Deadpool
and Angela and I'm prepping up the story
line for Batman Return of the Bruce
Wayne the whole time travel he's a Cav
he's a pirate he's a he's a caveman he's
a viking yeah I mean like like Benny I
know what you like when I did Howard the
dock man I know exactly where you're
coming from like like the video is like
23 24 minutes but the most interesting
part of the video is the controversy
like Howard the Duck and Disney I didn't
even have controversy like okay okay
real quick about my my struggles with
the entities so I know of the entities
they're always mentioned but I always
assumed that there was more to them than
what was mentioned in the war of the
greenlanders and everything so I said
here for days looking for more
references no Jeff Dawns introduced them
in the black as night which is where I
saw them Y and the only other reference
has been in the war of the Green
Lanterns which is where I read them and
there is nothing else that's it that's
it so I'm like this one's a steak this
one's a damic bull this one isn't I mean
yeah it's it's like like like how I did
how duck because the themselves I
thought the core when I went through the
cores there was a whole bunch of back
history on spin-offs that I didn't know
about and I had to go look up that
doesn't exist for this yeah no um Howard
the I I did I did Howard the Duck
because people wanted to see Howard the
Duck after you know like with everything
that's G on in Guardians of the Galaxy
Howard the Duck is is like like dumb
like he is not interesting at all I
didn't I didn't even like I was like man
I'm not really even sure I want to do
this but I'll try to make it interesting
it's I mean okay man thing giant siiz
man thing issues number four and five
issue number four is Howard the Duck
returning to the Earth 616 Universe he
fights a giant frog issue number five he
fights a a vampiric bovine a vampire cow
like that's Howard the Duck he does
that's what he does that's what he does
he he fights he's almost like a
cartoonish Hellboy yeah I mean he he was
he was like Deadpool before there was
Deadpool but he's not as violent as dead
exactly right so it's it's like he's a
silly character and like the controversy
like Steve Gerber suing Marvel and
Disney like we're going to sue you if
you don't change how the duck like that
was more interesting than like how D
publication history yeah yeah so well
and like I was saying in our our chat
before
like his stories are pretty short too MH
like some of them are literally like
Sunday morning like comic strips I mean
yeah that's it okay I'm I'm going I'm
going to blow Rob's spot here this was
hilarious cuz we have we have a little
comic book YouTuber chat we kind of we
we bounce ideas off each other and Rob
started Howard of the duck and it was
like four days later that Rob sends the
message out oh my God Howard the Duck is
stupid why did I do this this was the
worst idea I ever had yeah like this is
a really bad idea like like I don't care
about this character at all like how are
the duck is
dumb I mean there was a reason why the
film sucked in 1986
guys I just's reading this like and this
is why I don't do obscurities I mean
that's there's a reason why it's
considered to be one of the worst movies
ever to be created in the history of
Cinema because it's based off a concept
that's not that
interesting so yeah the hopefully the
video will be interesting but you know
just don't give me a [__] if it sucks
because how yeah he's kind of just he's
kind of just a character to laugh at I
don't think anybody expects anything
else that's exactly it man like he rides
around with She-Hulk for a while he's
part of Generation X like Franklin
Richard turn into like a rip off a
Witchblade and grow boobs uh no but he
turns into a mouse at one
point yeah it's it's it's like what
issue is that and where can I get it
serious don't I don't care
oh I'm sorry I need to be more sarcastic
you prly didn't cover this because I've
seen this
and hold on oh no wait it's not Howard
the Duck it's somebody else that does
that there another one of those stupid
cartoon characters that turns into like
a girl with like a Witchblade ripoff and
grows massive
boobs and complains about back pain it's
hilarious so anyway I'll show you after
this but so I guess that's it we're
gonna close it up for the day sure yeah
I think we're gonna I'm hoping to catch
up on Civil
War awesome man this week G catch up on
Batman technically it's the end of the
week so like next week but right but I'm
hoping to at least upload the rest those
videos in in the next few weeks and then
move on to uh some other stuff like
House of them or Annihilation or
something yeah yeah all right guys well
I mean I think that pretty much wraps it
up so uh yeah yeah we're I guess we'll
catch you guys later totally
salutations
exor I've never said